right now there is a live stream on
YouTube showing War at one of the
largest nuclear power plants I believe
in the world is it in the world Jack
uh certainly one of the largest in
Europe as far as we can tell they may
have larger ones in Asia but this is the
largest one in Europe you can actually
watch and on live video on YouTube we we
pulled at first we had this breaking
news report and it said they're shelling
you know or firing on a nuclear power
plant and so I titled this stream like
reportedly doing this and then Jack was
like I've got the live stream and then
we started watching the live stream and
you can see fire you can see what looks
like emergency vehicles you can see
military equipment you can see some kind
of uh firing upon this Nuclear Power
Plant
so not uh not confidence building to say
the least but certainly one of the most
shocking developments we've seen so far
and we've got a lot of other updates too
Russian uh warplanes entered and be very
careful how I described this violated
Swedish airspace and Japanese airspace
people need to realize that Russia is
like 50 miles from Sweden and 50 miles
from Japan and 50 miles from the United
States so they certainly are very close
to all of these countries and uh there's
there seems to be a real possibility of
dramatic escalation uh here so we'll
definitely get into all of that and we
also have this some of the craziest news
Russia Today RT completely shut down I
mean this is crazy there's I don't how
many people work at this company dozens
a hundred or more all lost their jobs
RT just said an interruption in business
there's what gets crazy
social media has labeled Americans uh
like Twitter as labeled like Russian
State media and Lee Kemp who is an
anti-war I think it's fair to say he's
left right leftist is that I guess he's
pretty seems pretty Centrist to me he's
double-headed but he's definitely
anti-war he's an anti-war
anti-establishment guy Spotify took his
podcast off the air the crazy thing is I
don't think his podcast is affiliated
with Russia it's like a YouTube channel
that he made it was Neil Young demanding
you take it down it must have been but
uh he did work he did have a show on
Russia Today called redacted tonight so
I don't know if he's still doing that
but this is crazy like War hysteria we
are seeing this in real time they're
banning Russians from sporting events
from video games like FIFA's like we're
not gonna have Russians in our video
game did you did you hear they banned
Russian cats Russian cats from the Cat
shows what there's white people have
lost their minds well there's a report
we'll just real quick um we'll just go
through we have a sponsor tonight but I
want to we'll go through introduction
sorry to cut you off but uh we got Jack
busovic hanging out hey welcome me back
uh very good to be back here it's been
been a minute but I'm about a month
since uh since I've been on good to see
Ian good to see everybody good to be in
the compound right on Daniel Turner
power of the future always great to be
with you fine folks and and with Jack
we've done this before and it's good to
see you my friend always a pleasure
thank you I'm Seamus Coughlin of Freedom
Tunes we upload a new animated cartoon
every single Thursday which means we put
one up today about Biden State of the
Union I think you guys will really enjoy
it it's so good yeah thank you very much
awesome thank you thank you please check
it out Ian crossing over here from Ian
crossland.net the energy Fields Lively
I'm ready to roll with it let's go it
feels like a nuclear fire tonight I'm
excited to talk about this a little bit
see what's going on before we get
started my friends we actually have an
awesome sponsor it is bio trust head
over to eat right and feelwell.com to
pick up your keto Elevate
mctc C8 MCT oil powder this stuff's
great it's it's like a creamer of some
sort I don't know I like mixing it into
my coffee it tastes really really good
and it provides you with that Key Energy
and mental Clarity increased energy
appetite management I've been doing I
started doing keto maybe like seven
months ago and then weaned into kind of
a basic low carb but it's been working
really really well for me and I love uh
the biostuff uh bio trust biohost stuff
the bio trust keto Elevate if you go to
eat right and feelwell.com you get 51
off a 60-day money-back guarantee you
will get C uh only C8 the most ketogenic
MCT for better energy appetite
Management Mental Clarity I did mention
that keto Elevate personally it is my
favorite and I'm a big fan of BioTrust
because they help support this show so I
always want to say these are the kind of
companies that you should be supporting
because they support the work we do back
at a time of uh you know activism this
is really really important you'll get
free shipping on every order and for
every order today BioTrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date BioTrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
Hungry kids please help bio trust hit
their goal of six million meals this
year you will get free VIP live health
and fitness coaching from biotrust's
Team of expert nutrition and health
coaches for life with every order and
their free e-report the top 14 ketogenic
foods with every order so again eat
right and feel well special thanks and
don't forget also go to timcast.com
we're going to have a members only
podcast about half an hour long they
usually are up around 11 or so p.m so
after we end this show we do the members
only portion of the show where we talk
about you know um let's just say it's
Unleashed there's more swearing and uh
crass language and discussions so that's
available at timcast.com but as a member
you're helping keep all of our
journalists employed and we're eternally
grateful for all of the support we do
get and also don't forget to Nuke that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends let's
just jump in to this first story we have
the report here from ABC News plant
spokesman says Russian troops have begun
shelling Europe's largest nuclear power
station in Ukraine plant spokesman says
Russian troops have begotten shelling it
that's basically the news that's it but
we're not stopping there
we actually have this live stream
um I can't read Cyrillic so I don't know
who is the person who has the live
stream up it's not us but someone has
been able to get a live stream of the
plant you can see there's some smoke uh
coming out of it the camera has moved
periodically but let me just do this let
me jump to the store it seems it seems
to be the name of the plan itself so I
think it might be like oh okay it's the
actual right oh so you're right yeah
yeah
all right well there you go so we
actually have uh some photos that
appears to show uh still grabs and video
clips showing the actual shelling you
can see this happening right now
I I would be uh I would love to have had
uh someone who knows the finer mechanics
of a nuclear power plant to tell us what
this could mean what could happen
because apparently they've already hit
so like have they hit all of the of the
power of the power station well
there's lots like at any nuclear
facility that you're going to be
involved in and you know someone who's
you know as I say as a military officer
I've got have done you know some basic
battle damage assessment training so
just like any military facility or
large-scale new um Power Plant you know
there's going to be lots of outlier
buildings administrative buildings
Office Buildings
um there's way more buildings around
this thing than the actual nuclear
reactors that have the rods in them that
have the ability to to melt down or
anything like that now that being said
um it's not a good idea to have a
firefight at a nuclear pan plan to be
firing artillery and throwing grenades
and and all the rest of that for various
very obvious reasons so this is is this
uh what is this we have this this image
here
is that what it is that I'm saying that
wrong exactly well it looks like yeah it
looks like in English there's things up
but in in this really like there was
there was a k so stop but there's like
it's it's like zapore
but uh this is just North of Melissa
pole and that's what just north of
Crimea near the Sea of azov
and so it's so it's on the daneper river
so every every nuclear plant needs a
water source right it's your basic
nuclear power
um uh value proposition so the same
reason by the way why most why a lot of
uh US Navy ships as uh all U.S carriers
and all U.S submarines are nuclear
powered because obviously they have yeah
you know access to water preventable
access to water
um I was going to say though Russia has
attempted and it's you know kind of on
again off again to make a
nuclear-powered cruiser so actually with
the capability of essentially being able
to file fire cruise missiles yeah as
this massive nuclear-powered platform
which even the US doesn't do
so what's what what are we doing here
what's this is this the is is this just
a shocking moment it's a flash in the
pan and maybe nothing bad'll happen or
uh well it seems I mean it seems this is
again this is part of Russia's strategy
right they are trying to take over all
the Strategic key points of Ukraine and
their weather is trying to do really is
cut the entire country of Ukraine in
half using that the never River as their
essential boundary so either they're
coming down on the north towards Kiev
they're coming up from the south through
uh starting obviously in Crimea which
they had already annexed in 2014 coming
up north they already took the city of
Curson so the next logical move for any
military procession in this was that you
would you would continue up the river
did you see that uh map from lukashenko
Belarus showing the attack into Moldova
though right yeah what do you think
about that
um I mean that could be a lot of things
no we already know that Russia does have
some troops in that separatist region of
transnistria so it could have been a
reference to that I mean the the quality
of the map was hard to kind of really
make out if there was any writing on it
or anything like that and obviously you
know everybody knows that you know I
live with a uh I have a live-in
translator when it comes to this part of
the world my wife uh being Belarusian
and uh so we weren't able so I was asked
I asked her if she could see anything on
there she said I couldn't really see
anything but I remember the night that
this all started
um we were down in CPAC and we were
staying at this place had like crappy
Hotel Wi-Fi
um nice hotel but crappy Wi-Fi down in
Orlando and Putin's up giving his speech
and she's like translating it in real
time and then I'm tweeting it out and
then zelinski's coming up giving his
response and people are all like you
know how's how's getting this stuff so
fast I'm like I have a translator
that's always the most difficult things
I've seen a lot of videos of Putin's
statements and I don't know that
someone's translated it properly you
know do you trust a random person on the
internet just posting quotes you know
what I mean there was a funny moment of
that everyone in the fog of War that's
right funny moment in 2007 with with
Condi rice when she was meeting with
Medved give I remember and she kicked
the translator out of the room because
she speaks Russian and she said you're
not true like she accused the the
Russian train translator of purposely
the American translators of like either
not purposely but she accused the
American translator of botching the
translation to a point that it was
distracting her and so she wants the
translator to believe how many times
that's pretty badass candy yeah that's
an example how many times you think this
is happening today like over and over
and over again yeah already there we
were talking about mistranslations in
like Islam and that the word power and
force also mean God in in Arabic yeah
and like come on talk about a mystery
and you're listening to the MSNBC
translation of the State of the Union
yeah I was going to say they don't even
translate Biden proper
um just an update on as what we're
seeing and the stream is freezing now so
I mean we might be losing
um you know our ability to see what's
going on at this uh Power Plant but
Ukraine's energy Ministry and again fog
of War grain of salt all the normal you
know couching statements and uh
corollary so we have to say but
Ukraine's energy Ministry is now
claiming that firefighters have been
fired at by Russian troops while trying
to put out the fire I don't because
they're going directly into an active
it's possible
um
it's entirely possible yeah if you're a
firefighter and there's conflict they
don't know who you are they might fire
upon you but I just I'm I'm really not a
fan of these comic book villainy claims
that that come out from the west and to
be honest even from you know Russia oh
we don't want Ukraine to get nukes or
whatever or we're trying to de-notsify
Putin saying you know we're gonna have
an antifa thing or whatever that's
ridiculous but but the idea you know
that we we're hearing the the absolute
comic book villainy of both sides from
both sides the propaganda is the
Russians are evil and they got these
these videos of pow Russian uh pows
crying and saying like I didn't know
they were going to make me kill women
and children or whatever and I'm like
dude
Don't parade around pows to me because I
don't trust them when they say that
right you've captured them their their
lives are at risk the Ukrainian uh
Special Forces command said we're not
going to take prisoners anymore and a
lot of people were like well that's an
admission of a war crime they were like
no more capture if we do we're gonna
slow I think what do they say Slaughter
like pigs or something yeah but that
actually I did see some people pushing
back on that and as we were just saying
that may have been kind of a translation
thing where the the connotation may have
been more like you we're going to kill
you in battle so you won't you won't be
alive for us to take prisoner right as
opposed to we're we're not going to
allow you to surrender no they they
tweeted in English something and then
deleted it
yeah there was like a tweet no that was
so I think that was either Kiev
independent or Kiev post that was that
was covering what was said but they may
have been going off of the
mistranslation right right but again I
mean so here's what I keep saying
throughout all of this right and the one
thing I've instituted
um with all my team is saying I we're on
a 24-hour you know rule with all this
stuff because how many stories have come
out since the beginning of this conflict
almost it's I think one week I think
we're at the one week Mark today right
um that within 24 hours have been
completely debunked right this shelling
or this pilot or Snake Island right it
sounds like a Hollywood script right it
sounds like your whole movie yeah you're
like like a movie script and you're and
and at first you know oh my gosh this is
this is I can't believe it and then it
turns out I can't believe it but you
actually can't believe it right yeah so
keep in mind that you know you're seeing
these situations and it's it's meant to
emotionally affect you and emotionally
hook you and the Western media by the
way has been lead and Bounds beyond
anything Russia has put out in terms of
their information operations here so
kind of one little corollary I threw out
there was you know the sort of debunked
all of Russia gate right because it
wasn't wasn't the predicate for
russiagate the idea that the Russians
wherever these Masters at information
Warfare they dominated the Global
Information environment and that it
turns out that okay well here's Russia
in an actual shooting War which they
would really need to have their best
info Ops up and they're you know
screaming about genocide and Nazis and
sure you you know we can talk about the
azov Battalion and we can be very
truthful about what's going on but at
the same and and yes there is shelling
in donbask yeah 100 but it's not the
exact same thing that they're alleging
they got the the the Instagram hot babes
of Russia coming out against Vladimir
Putin's against their own government
he's done and so much times yeah and
some of these uh I thought I thought was
going to do it but these Instagram
models are like the daughters of
government officials
see the thing is
this is the power of influence War the
U.S controls Instagram these young women
make money off Instagram and feel social
acceptance from likes when that's
threatened to be taken away from them
they immediately come out and say no no
I support the other country that is
scary like corporations do whatever time
does yeah exactly absolutely it's
terrifying when Tick-Tock controlled by
China is operating here for the exact
same reason and what will happen if
China moves into Taiwan Tick Tock is
going to light up and all of these
American tick-tockers are going to be
like what Taiwan is China and China has
a right and blah blah Taiwan is the
Republic of China technically it is
China and the CCP is an invading Force I
don't know you had a tick tock no I
don't actually I think we've got banned
from maybe I do have a tick tock I don't
remember I don't think I do but it's a
Republic of China that's the uh the real
government of China the Republic that
was basically pushed onto the island
I restore the Republic I love the uh the
the thing that the West that America has
exported to the world as the awful
hyperbolic language that can Sergey
lavarov the Russian foreign minister is
talking about the denotification of
Ukraine and they are Nazis I'm like you
sound like a 17 year old kid in like a
high school debate team like are we all
talking on this awful hyperbolic I'm
gonna get rid of the Nazis from Ukraine
it's just it's awful how someone who's
been a Statesman for 60 years it sounds
like like a tick tock kid right now like
a boomer yeah it's just unbelievable
well he's got to hold on to that though
because that's now the official line
yeah no he has to it's just embarrassing
because I think we need to remember too
that you know any of these statements
now that that lavrov is making and
you're right that he's he's been known
as someone who's actually pretty highly
respected in the International Community
even though you know obviously they
disagree with him on a lot but all of a
sudden he's throwing that away to you
know throw off these these little like
you know potshot like WD WWE kind of
lines and the reason is though that's
all getting played internally yeah right
and so they're going to show that to the
Russian people and they're going to and
it's it's going to play into this new
narrative and it's the same narrative
that of course Biden and all of these
companies that are coming out now and
and banning Russians you've got oh the
thing I was going to say earlier Canada
has said this Canadian minister of uh
Transportation has said they're holding
a charter plane in Canada full of
Russian Nationals and they're not going
to let it go right so the internal
narrative in Russia right now is that
it's the world versus you and guess what
the world is playing right into yep well
I gotta say they cross the line here
check out the story from NBC News
International cat Federation bans
Russian felines from competitions we
surrender it is time to give up
Federation
too much which hosts over 700 Cat shows
a year said it cannot just witness these
atrocities and do nothing what look at
these cats no it's like okay I can
understand that I can understand the
sentiment I can't witness the these
atrocities and not do anything but like
that that's the thing you chose to do
you that wasn't your only option you
like did the Russian so so what if it
like what if an American is a Russian
cat is that the issue or is it like well
or is it like take him into the streets
sorry Oliver some of course 60 year old
librarian has been waiting to show her
Russian blue all year and it's like
she's from you know Idaho and now she's
like what what do you mean I can't go to
the cat show it's like you're a
communist so it's not even that way look
at that look at that no it's not bread
in Russia no cat so you could be an
American oh okay they think they're
genetics imported or registered in any
way but what if that cat is a citizen in
another country why is where they came
from so important to these people those
cats are just seeking a better outcome a
better life for themselves
exactly have they been bugged is that
the problem
back to citizenship I love this timeline
they're just training
dream lines
these people like one you almost got me
on that one the group said the new
regulation last through May 31st and
will be reviewed as and when necessary
like is any of this necessary yeah yeah
I don't understand democracy so like
it's it's but this is This Is War
hysteria this is the same thing as the
mass formation psychosis we heard about
during covid yeah this is people being
like Russia I need to put a Ukrainian
flag in my Twitter account and ban the
cats oh my goodness there's there's
another sentence here I really have to
read
um
on top of that our Ukrainian fellow
feline fanciers are desperately trying
to take care of their cats and other
animals in these trying circumstances
there are far greater concerns there
far greater than say like and we're
going to retaliate by Banning Russian
cats
the announcement is the latest blow to
Russia which has been hit with sanctions
by a number of countries they're reeling
what if you own I mean dude after this
is stroking his cat and he's like that's
right he was like no yes yes
what do you mean she cannot compete he
like he looks at his shelf and he's got
all of his awards from the cat show
I am a feline fancier
that was great alliteration
a lot of alliteration did you find out
if you have a Russian cat
in Russia they're gonna come take it no
no wait in Russia are born bread or or
because if we're not the cat could have
been bred there but then could have
given birth in another country wait what
yeah if if the cat are you suggesting
yeah
it's anchor kitties
yeah yeah we've gone for in 20 minutes
we've gone from the nuclear firefight to
Anchor kitties yeah the most important
whichever there's like I think 11 11.
this is tough because this will be
ripping families apart if it goes
through are you going to separate
there's a great restaurant in DC that is
a Russian restaurant I'm almost
reluctant to say the name because I
don't want to give them names well they
smashed the window but they're smashing
the windows a friend of mine ate there
last night and said I've been coming to
this restaurant for like the 20 years
I've lived in DC and it is a Russian
restaurant but they're Americans they
just have Russian Heritage and they make
Russian food and now there's like a
boycott the restaurant and they must be
like you put me through friggin covet
and now you're putting me through this
like I just make borscht yeah how am I
responsible for this when well my
response was when I saw FIFA had banned
Russian clubs and teams or whatever from
the game I was just like it's just the
stupidest thing ever and I said you know
what the Russian people are to blame to
all of this they should be punished
hold on the funny thing is when I
tweeted I despise appeals to emotion
right yes the left went nah you were
trending you were trending for like two
days
I was specifically referring to the
translators more than one there were
three different translators who cried
while translating and that was the viral
story of course I tweeted that because I
tweeted about it a bunch of different
times and I made videos about it but
that doesn't play well when they want to
like criticize like it's the weirdest
thing ever because I've been very like
Pro zalenski and like been supportive
Ukraine the entire time so I don't know
what they're trying to smear but when
they go when they go nuts on this and
then I tweet we jokingly because they're
all basically like me just screwing
around when I say we must punish Russian
Americans or my favorite tweet was I
said whoa how do we know that Russian
Americans aren't secretly working for
Putin or worse
Trump that did not make any of them
angry or when I said punish Russian
civilians like that that didn't make
anybody angry but how dare you question
appeal to him the the sobbing
translators okay well y'all just banned
cats so what gets lost your mind what
gets me about removing the Russians
teams from the video game Sports is like
uh uh okay I understand trying like
World War II we put the Japanese
citizens in internment camps hardcore I
don't know if it was with the right or
wrong move maybe they were spies maybe
did the right thing but like I used to
play Civilization and Hitler's never
been any ever let any of the German
countries if you play Civilization you
play Germany Hitler has never been in
the game they've eradicated the the
memory of that man from the video game
still 80 years later they're still
eradicating the memory so like yeah the
Russian teams are gone from Sports this
year what if in 80 years there's still
like pretending Russia never existed
it's it's effing terrifying so here's
what here's what gets me on all of these
you know and it's it's de-platforming
deep for me and cancel it we're trying
to use cancel culture
the same way that you know to affect
Russia but I I don't think they kind of
underst like this this was a planned
operation this wasn't like Putin woke up
one day and said oh we're just gonna do
this did you see the report that
apparently Xi Jinping said don't invade
until after the Olympics are over
maybe maybe
I'm skeptical but at the same time you
know I think this is something that was
planned out for months in advance I
guarantee you that Putin went around to
all of like the top oligarch anyone who
has any actual sway within Russia and
explained this is what's going to happen
next year so you need to set up your
stuff however you want to set it up and
and Daniel you know this these guys have
stuff off the books in every country
around the world it's not in their names
it's not in their kids names yeah you
can take their Yachts because you know
it's them but they've got Mansions you
don't know about they've got planes you
don't know about and they're going to
use them and they're going to be fine so
these sanctions aren't going to hurt
anyone important in Russia you're going
to hurt the regular people you're going
to hurt the disabled athletes that want
to go to the Paralympics you're going to
go after the oncology researchers that
are trying to help people with cancer in
uh in Russia right you're going to hurt
all of those regular people behind the
scenes that's number one and number two
is you're going to turn all of them not
against Putin they're going to be
against you because you put the
sanctions on what would you if you had
been the president when this happened
last week what would have been an
adequate response
well I mean
cure cancer you have to you have to go
back and say you know we we responded to
escalation with more escalation right so
it's we've been ratcheting up things as
they've been ratcheting up things and so
from the start you should have not been
doing that that's always the wrong the
wrong move obviously I think uh you know
we needed Biden to have because we knew
the invasion was coming Biden should
have had a conversation with Putin a
long time ago and he did and he should
have said if you hit Ukraine I will hit
Mass I'm sorry Joe Biden he should have
been like come on man
Donald Trump reportedly told Putin if
you if you try to take Ukraine I will
hit Moscow he said all those beautiful
golden turrets will be destroyed yep do
you remember my favorite though he told
she the same thing if you go for Taiwan
I'll hit Beijing yeah and the story was
that both she and Putin were like like
kind of shocked that someone would tell
them I will kill millions of civilians
if you take a if you engage in regional
conflict remember Trump timed the
original Syria strikes for when Xi
Jinping was meeting at Mar-A-Lago over
dinner and there's you know there's a
story that as cake was being served they
leaned in and told Xi Jinping that the
strikes were taking place that's right
yeah but do you remember when when Putin
just met with when Biden just met with
Putin a couple of months ago he came
back and he said we talked about seven
things that I told him were off limits I
mean right then and there I was like
well what if I'm Number Eight you know
like so the seven things that you can't
hit seven American assets I we went
through seven things that he can't touch
that was after the Cyber attack the
closed Colonial pipeline so right off
the bat Putin I mean if anything he
watched the state of the union he felt
more bold than me I was gonna say well I
didn't hit any of those seven things so
I'm good to go and if you watch the and
if you watch the Super Bowl halftime
show he's like they don't deserve to
live anymore like they're all we should
just invade the West completely I think
people need to recognize that Vladimir
Putin is passionate uh and he's old
which means he's got to make whatever
move he's gonna make now because he's
almost 70 years old so I think I think
Russia is going to win what they want to
win I don't I I we we already have these
crazy stories about NATO's involved
they're 100 involved they're just
playing weird semantic games Latvia has
apparently voted to allow their citizens
to join the fight on the Ukrainian side
now how is that not declaring war it's
so ridiculous well our our military
isn't involved we're just sending waves
of our own citizens with guns into
Ukraine to shoot you that to me is
absurd plus you've got the arming you've
got the the uh resources we'll put it
that way being given to Ukraine so so
it's ridiculous that we're at this point
where it's like well if NATO gets
involved they're involved yeah so this
is we're back under this is something
that I've noticed you know kind of
zipping around on Twitter reading a lot
of stuff that we seem to have kind of
forgotten the sort of rules of the Cold
War like the reason that we don't go
directly
um bullet to Bullet we don't fire upon
Russian assets and Russian assets don't
fire on us so we have these proxy wars
right to we in Afghanistan throughout
the 70s and eight late 70s early 80s
then we had the Vietnam War prior to
that where again Russia of course was
supporting the Vietcong and supporting
the NVA and then we got involved in the
South but Russia didn't actually send
you know they may have had a couple
advisors but they didn't send forces
down
um same deal with Korea right during the
Korean War
Russia didn't get directly involved some
air assets but they sent China in they
had North Korea but they didn't go in
themselves same idea for us we don't
want to get into this shooting war with
another nuclear power so we end up doing
all these proxy wars and essentially if
you're looking at it from Russia's
perspective they view the current regime
of the government of Ukraine and the
Ukrainian military as an American or at
least Western proxy Force since uh 2014
since 2014. one of the CIA since the
coup instigated is it is it like
official that the CIO was involved or
just assumed I mean they were certainly
involved and they're certainly Western
needed yeah there were certainly Western
assets involved I mean you can you can
have a debate about you know who started
it or who you know whether or not it was
justified but it certainly was U.S
supported and that blockaded and like
hindered their ability to get oil into
the Black Sea so that's why he took
Crimea almost instantly after that
well it I mean it changed a lot of
things obviously but they were looking
at a situation where remember the
Russian Black Sea Fleet it's at that
Port of Sebastopol has always been there
right that's always been a Russian naval
port and that's their major port uh
their major navy base on the Black Sea
so they were never going to give that up
they just they just weren't going to
it's their only warm water Port it also
grants them access to the Mediterranean
yeah
with uh the Bosphorus in Turkey because
turkey controls it's Russia's already in
a weakened position with that being yeah
with turkey being in NATO I mean how do
they get through the boss for us well so
I mean that's why they're taking Ukraine
so they go over land if if you need to
get through the bus for us you know just
because turkey says no it doesn't mean
you can't get through yeah I think there
was a big issue with that because Russia
did it no I think the U.S did somebody
was like we don't care and just went and
turkey was like yeah shipping routes man
I think the Suez is also underrated I
think a big part of why the military
buildup in the Middle East that the
United States has been doing is to
protect the Suez Canal and the shipping
100 but also look at if you want to go
through and actually look at what we can
see not the apocalyptic you know version
of Greta Thunder climate change but the
actual climate change effects that if
you look at that Northern sea route
that's opening up across essentially the
Arctic Ocean Russia is a clear
beneficiary of all of this because you
can make it from Dalian China to
Rottenberg Dan Denmark in like
two-thirds the time or even half the
time that you would take that you would
need to go through the South China Sea
and then the Suez Canal if you cut that
all around that's the reason that Russia
knows that going 15 years from now
they're going to be the ones in charge
of that Northern sea route I would
advise anyone if it's listening to the
show to pull up like a map a Google map
or like some sort of map follow along
yeah because it's really cool type in
the names of these places and you can
understand geographically what what's
going on let's let's do this too um I
got the story out of UPI Russian
warplanes violate Sweden's airspace
reportedly uh Sweden's Air Force
dispatched jas-39 Gripen aircraft in
response to two Russian su-27s and two
su-24s briefly entering its airspace
east of gotland island in the Baltic Sea
we also have reports Japan's has a
Russian helicopter violated its airspace
and scrambled fighter jets to give you
context on on the the uh the sheer size
of Russia we come over here to uh where
we got Google Earth pulled up here's
Japan right it it's Russia right here
there's validova stock and so you've got
these islands we're talking about what
50 to 100 miles away from Japan that's
Russia if we zoom out and go all the way
across rush over to Europe check it out
not only do you have Moscow right here
with Finland you have kaliningrad which
is right here it's an oblast and this is
Scotland so Russia is massive on top of
that let's just go over here and point
at the fact that Russia is 50 miles from
the United States so they got a lot
they're they're spread out very thin it
doesn't mean that uh they can win but it
does mean that they can reach many
different people very very quickly and
if Russia's been preparing this for some
time they can easily move troops and
armaments into various regions argue
like across like very close to many
different countries you'd expect to be
on the other side of the planet without
anyone knowing or at the very least
without setting off alarm bells and
pissing anybody off it's their own
country it's Russia so they put troops
in the East and the west and they can
effectively be ready to fight on on you
know all spheres and one of the things
that Jack was just talking about when it
comes to the Arctic is we've been
watching the Ukraine build up for a long
time the troop build up on the Ukraine
border for a long time the the Putin's
Army buildup in in the Arctic has been
massive it gets very little coverage and
the ones who are the most afraid of the
Norwegians because they are they're not
members of NATO right they're not I
don't believe they're even part of the
EU they're the largest oil and gas
producer up there but Russia is saying
no no no this is this is ours the Arctic
is ours right and there's a reason why
clearly they want the Arctic
um they have they are building enormous
and have built enormous uh LNG ports
along their North Coast in terms of
export LNG now directly to to the world
in terms of military force I mean it's
it's it's pretty clear that Russia does
have a strong command presence when it
comes to the Arctic at this point the
United States I think only has one
Icebreaker at this point and it's it's
always you know it's kind of in uh you
know it's always stuck in the air it's
always yeah yeah very good but it's like
it's barely you know barely works very
well China has a ton of ice Cutters but
of course uh China does not have any
actual access to the Arctic so if China
this is another part of that
relationship this burgeoning
relationship that we're seeing between
China and Russia if China wants access
to the Arctic they've got to go through
Russia if Russia wants their financial
backstop they need to go to China the
one you kick them off Swift will one
belt one road is right there for you so
but you know Ian an answer to your
question if I want to curb these you
know excessive of and obviously
aggressive and insane behaviors of the
Russian government you know you can say
all right we're going to try to put
sanctions on Russia but obviously
they've priced that into this
proposition
how we tried putting sanctions or using
economic leverage on China on the
oligarchs of the CCP on CCP leaders
going after them going after the Yuan
using anything that we can there because
obviously China and China and the United
States do not have a strong trade
relationship we never really have but
China and the United States oh yeah
obviously Russia you said China Russia
in the United States Russia in the
United States you think that's just
because we don't have sea routes and
we're not right because we China and the
United States is kind of right next to
each other I mean I guess the Russians
and the Americans do have see plenty of
C connections we just they just don't
have much to trade what is it why are
they not a great trade trade leader is
there so massive is what a man who why
the Russians Russia in America not trade
leaders is it just because it's like
uninhabitable most of Russia well most
of Russia is uninhabitable that those
those you're yes on a map it's it's
massive but a lot of that area is either
unused or it's not arable or they just
don't have the people the population to
uh Putin was trying to hire you know
Farmers for Siberia at one point or like
recruit people to come in and oh yeah
give them a place for free
right they were talking about bringing
you know the South African Farmers up
there as a way to you know get away from
the issues they were facing the farm
murders down in South Africa but
um yeah for the majority of that area
right you're you're really only looking
at it in terms of resources and when it
comes to those resources as Daniel of
course would be able to explain much
better than me
um and knows what's better than me you
know we are competitors in those areas
yeah it's pretty terrifying to think of
the 21st century and all those resources
in Russia with with the with the actual
amount of power Russia has which is not
that much and the amount of land and
that's very very very much that's why
the currency stuff doesn't hit them the
way that we would expect it to because
they still have the resources but I
would disagree with saying they're not
that powerful they're they have what
like 60 of the military capability of
the entirety of NATO
they are they are our largest we are
their largest customer for fertilizer
right around 800 million dollars a year
in fertilizer that now probably we're
not going to buy what are we going to do
and what it's where we live in a rural
area you're getting ready to harvest in
a couple of weeks what are you putting
on your field you need about a hundred
pounds of fertilizer per acre so if I
have a 5 000 acre cornfield what am I so
do I just lose the crop so I have to buy
from somewhere else so what a corn price
is going to do what are wheat price
wheat prices have already doubled so
what are food so I mean we're worried
about oh the price at the pump and I am
I'm an energy guy I'm worried about the
price of the pump I'm worth this
November I can't imagine what food
prices are going to be and you want to
see violence yo wait till people already
hungry I might have misheard you you
said I thought you said we sell them buy
fertilizer from them yeah no we buy from
no the same and it's disturbing that we
buy it it's a serving that we buy
someone no it's disturbing that it might
get caught off it's disturbing that we
buy our Pharmaceuticals from China and
that is what I hate about globalism who
has outs who decided who's the Brain
Trust that said let's put these things
in the hands of our enemies let's let's
just let's just point out
how moronic the leadership of this
country has been Outsourcing to China
then we get coveted what does China do
they have their citizens across around
the world buy a PPE and ship it back to
China we don't make our own medicine you
have to be a special kind of stupid to
Outsource to China and then pick a fight
with with Russia who is going to be
who's going to be working with China so
now we're in this position where like
you brought up fertilizer but we've also
got vitamin C antibiotics now you get
Biden coming out in the State of the
Union Address being like we're going to
be investing in these these chips for
your computer chips and he's basically
signaling War may be coming and we will
lose Taiwan I can and I can verify that
first thing you said in case anyone
thinks that you're lying
um which you never would or you're
misrepresenting the truth married to an
Australian in November of 19. Andrew
said I was talking to my mind he's from
a rural town on the Outback and said my
mom said the weirdest thing happened
like she was at the grocery and this bus
of some Chinese people got up and they
bought everything she said like what the
heck was that she said and and then like
neighbors talk this is November of 19 he
was saying it's so weird everyone I
talked to in my little town says a van
of Chinese people will show up and they
will buy everything in the store and it
will disappear it was reported then and
that was the beginning I told their
citizens in other countries to buy PPE
and send it send it back yeah well it's
interesting because we've been talking a
little bit about nuclear weaponry and
mutually assured destruction one thing
not a lot of people consider is that
biological Weaponry is also considered
to be a Weaponry form of a weapon of
mass destruction and China literally
created one and released it I know that
there's still some debate around that
technically but I think it's pretty
straightforward and so I would say yeah
well it's so elaborate but if a country
accidentally detonated a nuke in another
Nation
this is the to again to the to the
moronic nature of our leadership for
fauci to be working in any way with any
groups that we're working with China you
are you are you are working with a group
that despises you yeah the Chinese
Communist party does not like us they
want to displace us they've insulted us
they they outright say they want to take
Taiwan they press us out China Sea they
sink Vietnamese ships this is not a
country we should be like let's give
them more stuff no let's give them more
access more resources more more
Authority and and it's just the sheer
absurdity of the U.S picking a fight
while giving things away is it's the
craziest thing so I suppose the the
neoliberal idea is that if we build
trade lines we won't go to well that was
it that was that was that was that was
Clinton
golden arches the golden arches series
is a version of it the idea that two
Nations that have a McDonald's have
never gone to war with each other it's
not true well and also now so it is it's
interesting because it is the case that
countries that stop trading with each
other are more likely to go to war
Libertarians down hard yeah uh but that
said yeah I mean a huge part of this I
think it's just indicative of our total
inability to defer gratification as a
people so there's this country that
we're trying to pick fights with while
at the same time still giving away our
resources to them because there's a
short-term gain for it uh in it for us
we're not actually thinking about a
long-term strategy here when they very
much are I wouldn't say that not trading
with a country makes you more likely to
go war with them I don't think that's a
fair oh that's fair I'm saying there's
I'm not okay
they were saying it the other way around
that if you trade it creates a
disincentive to go and this is what we
were told in the 90s when we gave China
most favored nation status under Clinton
right as they begin to grow and and
become a trading partner and as they get
a taste of ours we'll open them up and
and what they did they polluted they
polluted to get better access to
Halliburton Raytheon it's a very bizarre
almost Marxist idea that the way we
solve people's problems is just by
increasing access to resources or
Building Wealth and it's an issue of
materialism yeah and so we do see it
with Hyper capitalist uh ideologies as
well but they they meld together very
it's very ironic because people see like
hyper capitalism and communism as being
diametrically opposed but the reality is
this idea that we can solve people's
problems simply through materialism and
that they will become more evolved and
better people because their wealth has
grown as obviously completely backwards
and we're seeing the effects of that now
with China look at what we did in
Afghanistan we gave them all iPads but
they don't have internet materials it's
like well there you go congratulations
guys I think we need the US government
to heavily invest in some kind of public
infrastructure for protecting the
American people from uh nuclear war
perhaps we could build big underground I
don't know vaults and we'd call the
company something related that like
Vault uh vault tech vault tech vault
tech like technology with numbers all
Technologies in order to communicate
could we have certain armbands yes as an
example like a computer
now since the US dollar is going
completely hit boy or something you know
since the US dollar is going out of is
being devalued what could we use as
currency in this situation
the most logical answer of that question
would be hold on soda bottle caps
I can't think of anything else you can
melt the metal down it's very easy it
wouldn't make any sense
Daniel's like what is going on right I
assume it's a movie or a video game
Fallout I don't I don't know what we're
talking about I didn't even follow it
real quick when Jack said we could wear
something on a rest in Fallout you have
the pit boy and the pit boy shows your
health status I'm literally wearing a
whoop you're pretty close yeah
my heart rate and stuff but it doesn't
have the graphics but check it out when
I was getting sick the whoop knew I was
sick before I knew I was sick of course
and so did Google so did Jeff Bezos yeah
Jeff Bezos is like he like wakes up and
he goes to grab his coffee and then he
like opens a tap and he goes oh Tim's
sick dude wouldn't it be hilarious if
there was just this long con uh
sabotaging or like this idea of warfare
where the companies that own that uh IP
are actually like selling it to China
and then China ever so tweaked like I I
know this is healthy form we're gonna
tell them to do the less healthy thing
instead of something that's morale for
them because we're going to weaken him
as a person
you said that that's kind of freakishly
possible do you think so people drive
into swamps because their Google Maps
tell them too no I think it's possible
that I think it's possible that people
would listen to that absolutely
tiny little thing yeah before before it
guys before we get too far off this so
the the nuclear plant situation ton of
uh this is a tweet from Ilya uh lazovsky
the actual nuclear Specialists are
coming out of the woodwork to say that
no we would not see a Marvel movie style
explosion yes it is bad fuel could leak
there could be radiation that comes out
of that but let's not retweet government
pronouncements uncritically it is a
different kind of reactor than Chernobyl
uh you can scram it you can shut do
emergency shutdowns the concrete shells
they have on this thing are capable of
being hit by aircraft weighing 20 tons
and not going
um they are not melting down and it's
Ian you and I were just talking about
this before you know the reason
Chernobyl melted down is because they
were running a test and the test went
crazy it wasn't just some uh random Fire
that broke out and then it you know
ignited everything and sure Noble
because it exploded it shot nuclear
fissile material into the atmosphere I
believe in that it blanketed the area
right so like carbon if the corium just
melts it just falls into the Earth it
just falls down and then hits the cement
and then melts through the cement and
keeps melting through the ground until
right so we are not so fortunately for
everybody out there you know it crazy as
it is you are not in a situation where
this thing could melt down over this hey
they turn the chat on it looks like oh
no okay no they stopped it I see the
stream ended they did have a chat oh
they saw the stream yeah stream stream
ended no that would have been we'll see
if they haven't even knew they have a
new uh yeah
but does that have the chat up disabled
the chat is disabled oh I still have a
check going but maybe it's they disabled
the chat for the nuclear firefight I
can't tell
can you imagine can you imagine I mean
the ABCs are still there the artillery
is still there
can you imagine like if we were able to
document other historic events like this
if we were able to watch live streams
that had it occurred of like events in
World War II and see the chat and see
pickets and a lot of people were just
like yeah I still have a chat on mine
really oh you're on a different one yeah
someone else has aggregated a bunch of
live feeds hastings.com like oh he's
arrived right Williams here well I I
wonder The Charge of the Light Brigade I
wonder I wonder how much of it would
just be like crazy insane memes too
because that's I feel like what it's
gonna be today no it was I was talking
about this the megaminds ukrainians with
massive balls Meme and I'm like it was
just a really garbage meme but you've
got intelligence agencies spamming
pro-ukraine propaganda it works to a
certain degree look at all the people
that have put the Ukrainian Flags in
there in their Twitter profiles yeah
I'll tell you one of the things that
really triggered the establishment the
Lefty activists was when I said I
noticed everyone was flying West
Virginia's colors I was like it's about
time everyone recognized how awesome the
state is because you know West Virginia
University uses blue and gold they got
pissed at me for that I was like why are
you so mad as a joke about the colors
for West Virginia I think they really
believe this is like the end of Western
civil is this is like the beginning of
the end of Western Civilization that's
people have been so freaked out and
manipulated by Russia it's I understand
the fear of the Soviet Union communist
nuclear missile crisis but Russia is not
the Soviet Union it's a federation you
can argue there are a bunch of oligarchs
in control over there as well as you
could argue that in America that there
are and in China apparently oligarchs
are running the show and in Ukraine and
in Ukraine but but I do love what you
said because you have heard that a lot
from politicians this is an attack on
Western Civilization we have to defend
western civilization and the first thing
I thought of was if six weeks ago I said
something about Western Civilization you
would have called me like a white
nationalists absolutely right you know
so now we love Western Civilization
again you see Joe Biden when he said
that the people of Ukraine are fighting
for their Homeland and they're like they
have an iron will an Iron Will and it
was Lauren Southern point of that
pointed this out she was like that was
like every racist dog whistle that if
Trump said that they would start writing
article after article saying it so
especially her argument was he was
accidentally racist by their own
standards and she's right she's right
yeah absolutely just ignored it so you
know what they're doing by the way with
this they are gonna I guarantee you they
are gonna try to use this nuclear plant
situation as a way to get a no-fly zone
instituted you watch yeah that's exactly
what I can see this is where it's going
to go they're going to say turn around
and say you have to Institute this
because of the recklessness that we're
seeing because of the shelling and
you're gonna have to Institute a no-fly
zone at what whatever the cost I assure
you
in the event that happens they're going
to liken it to Chernobyl they're going
to say the risks of another Chernobyl
should never be allowed oh my goodness
so we are instituting a no-fly zone
Vladimir Putin marked my words I didn't
see Chernobyl the movie but was it scare
tactic or was it accurate this is a TV
show isn't it I thought it was I thought
it was fantastic I thought it was very
well done actually yeah but did it scare
people into like nuclear fear oh big
time Big Time I mean if you're if you're
someone who's anti-nuclear that's the
movie you want everywhere the the the
the Fukushima meltdown scared Angela
Merkel into canceling her whole
country's nuclear reactors and you want
to say but Germany doesn't have a lot of
tsunamis Angela like you you you
shouldn't be worried about that let me
tell you on Glenn miracle if a tsunami
hit Germany nuclear fallout is the least
right you've got a lot bigger but she
shut down the entire country's nuclear
program now they're buying LNG from
Russia and they're afraid to sanction
LNG that liquid natural gas which is
methane which because yeah yeah yeah and
because they don't have enough energy
what are there other natural gases than
methane that are no that's the
predominant one is methane and if you
look at Germany like the the amount of
Coast they have it's not that much so
you know where are they shutting down
these nuclear power plants it's just
Greta tunberg comes out and she said
those magic words she said how dare you
and everyone just collapsed and grasped
their hearts and well if we realize how
wrong they were for years we were
talking about damn you said I you and I
used to talk about this when we were
doing one America news that it was
always the Russians that were funding
these anti-fracking groups for years and
if you turned on so okay they banned RT
right so RT America isn't there I think
they're still up on YouTube for now you
can go to rt.com and it was down for a
little bit today well no they're they're
so let's let's do it what was
interesting and you know not to get into
the censorship angle but you could see
what Russia's strategic interests were
based on the story selection there and a
huge chunk of their programming was
devoted towards green groups was devoted
to anti-fracking was devoted to this
because so then you could watch that and
you could say oh well that's something
that Russia wants to push I wonder why
that is and then I talked to a guy who
understands energy but you'd sound like
a lunatic if you said that well just a
couple years ago people like oh take
your tinfoil like oh he wants to watch
RT to find out what the Russians want
let me know doesn't that make sense let
me pull the story follow let me let me
tell you about our two we got the story
from timcast.com staff of RT America
laid off as Network announces it is
halting production in a memo to its
employees RT America cited unforeseen
business Interruption events yeah it
could be War but let me let me tell you
let me tell you about uh uh Russia Today
and Sputnik I was at the RT and Sputnik
offices in 26 in 2016 during the
election with Cassandra Fairbanks and
the people in that office every single
one saved Cassandra was a pro-democrat
pro-hillary activist or individual they
were crying when Donald Trump started
winning and then when he won people were
crying how many rubles were you paid to
say that to him zero rubles all of the
rubles we know we know the dossier that
the ukrainians had nothing to do with no
no that Russia wanted Trump to win we
know this well you you look at the
content that RT has promoted the people
they've hired their anti-war
anti-establishment and typically
leftists like during Occupy Wall Street
people were like oh yeah RT like I knew
a ton of people who don't act by occupy
would be like you got to watch RT
because they were the ones telling the
truth about Occupy Wall Street or
another way to put it is promoting
anti-establishment protests United
States that could potentially
destabilize I thought RT and Al Jazeera
were great sources during the Syrian con
when they wanted to go and invade Syria
I was like what's really going on and
people it was like people like uh like
Lee Camp people like Lee Camp speaking
out against the Syrian war on RT I don't
know if he was on his RT show at that
point if you had started redacted at
night at that point look at this on his
first show Lee Camp he's uh anti-war
I've known him for a long time I always
thought of him as more of a lefty guy
redacted tonight was a show in artes has
rejected tonight has been canceled
because the U.S war machine can't handle
the truth if you want to follow my work
go to leadcamp.com but not only that his
show on Spotify so let me see he
retweeted a while ago it's probably on
mine I don't know if uh Twitter's gonna
let me pull it up because I make me log
in so here we go his his podcast on
Spotify has been taken down as well
which is insane because I don't think it
had anything to do with uh oh come on
you're gonna load or not Twitter's so
stupid let me see if I can pull it up
again I don't think it showed anything
to do with uh there we go with Russia
Today he says a great deal of anti-war
and leftist shows are currently being
deleted by Spotify including my personal
podcast Moment of clarity you can
continue to get all of my stuff by
signing up for my email list at
leadcamp.com
and rad indymedia.com my question is if
that's just Lee Camp's personal podcast
which he also has on YouTube Moment of
clarity he's at 18 000 subscribers
why did he get banned from Spotify
he was a Russian fear he was hired by RT
he's an American citizen RT America I
mean uh yeah technically RT I guess
paying his bills but that doesn't mean
they're telling him what to say look at
this Rachel Blevins who does not work
for RT anymore because RT doesn't exist
is labeled Russian State Affiliated
media on Twitter she's never going to be
able to get rid of that none of these
people are
yo I hope they do I mean oh this is
something I want to talk about imagine
Nawaz with how long is it you commit a
crime or some sort of transgression do
you have to bear the title of that just
think about what this means moving
forward the hysteria well when they are
labeling people with as Russians what
happens if this war escalates you think
internment camps are the question you
would be wrong no of course not
especially if as you said food's going
to get a lot more expensive and the
establishment isn't going to say that it
has anything to do with their
irresponsibility in printing trillions
of dollars into basing our currency it's
because of what the Russians are doing
in Ukraine blame them it's their fault
in your Russian next door neighbor if
you happen to have one is just as
culpable as anybody else or more
culpable than uh than we are certainly
and so no it's it's not out of the
question when food gets expensive and
you have to decide who gets it then the
prisoners are not the ones they're gonna
scapegoat some I'm not saying it's
necessarily gonna be the Russians but
they're going to scapegoat somebody it's
already irresponsible it's already
started yeah and it's it's clearly
already started they're being
scapegoated they're being escaped for
the inflation there and not just ever
like if you're from Russia if you're
from Belarus right and I've talked to
belarusians right I've heard from
Russians about this I heard you're
sleeping with them oh yeah that's one
way to put it uh they hate this
they hate this war but you have to
understand they are underneath their
regimes right these are not democracies
you can't actually judge this the exact
same way that you would somewhere else
right
um and I don't remember the United
States getting completely canceled every
American canceled because of the Iraq
War the Iraq invasion which was by the
way yes unilateral Invasion obviously
that doesn't justify uh the aggression
that Putin's doing right now but at the
same time you have to look at this and
say look these people are subjects of
their regimes they're subjects of
authoritarian leaders like lukashenko
like Putin they don't have any way to
effectively respond yeah they can
protest and then they all get arrested
just like up in you know Canada
um you know another Bastion democracy up
there and so you're going to turn around
and yet blame all of the people who just
want to live their lives who literally
just want to live their lives and don't
want to be involved in this I don't
think that our invasion of Iraq and
Libya are our current that we are doing
right now we're invading those countries
today right now uh I don't think it
justifies The Invasion but it definitely
explains it
well it destroys our moral standing in
the world and so how can you turn around
from a governmental perspective and say
well we disagree with you doing that
when you look at what the United States
by the way yes through NATO has done
throughout the years right and so when
you look at Libya when you look
Afghanistan when you look at Iraq you
just go around you could literally walk
place to place to place it's nothing but
death and destruction other than you
know the protection of some parts of
Europe which has been
why is someone yelling yeah what's up
dude I watched oh this is this is the
live stream okay this is uh that's the
live stream the next video yeah it's the
next video
I watched a video on Uday Hussein last
night because Rogan I heard him mention
was talking to Magic nois on a show
about how horrible saddam's kids were
and I was like oh yeah so Uday Hussein
it looks like he was just like daddy's
little boy who Saddam beat the hell out
of growing up and then Daddy was like
You can have anything you want son
anything every video you find of Uday
he's tripping his balls off it's like he
just takes psychedelics it's like he's
in it dude and he just beat that he was
just a
okay yeah this is a little off topic but
right America went in saying we got to
stop human atrocity and Uday was putting
people in like bleeding machines he was
a psychopath so but still The Invasion
is completely irrational let me pull
this tweet from Kyle Griffin Kyle
Griffin of course what is he uh uh MSNBC
producer says the National Association
of broadcaster says issued a statement
calling on broadcasters to stop carrying
russian-sponsored programming that's
affiliated with the Russian government
or its agents and what are the responses
you're saying Fox is off the air does
that include Fox no good for Fox right
so who right so who gets labeled a
Russian agent now because I remember in
the Mueller investigation during all of
Russia gate everyone was labeled a
Russian agent everyone yeah so this is
my prediction they're going to start
calling all Russians bad and then
they're going to start calling all
Republicans Russians well they've been
doing that for seven years I think that
you're seeing the culmination of that
right I think National Association of
broadcasters the CIA CEO of that is
still Biden's best friend Chris Dodd I'm
pretty sure I have to look at that I
think I thought Senator Dodd was the
head of the NAB which would be
interesting I mean every trade
Association has a former Senator
remember the Dodd Tim remember the Dodge
Kennedy sandwich exactly it's that that
Chris Dad it's interesting um the way I
mean we've said this before the left
constantly projects and so that's part
of why they're always accusing everyone
else of being racist they are extremely
obsessed with race and ethnic identity
that's why they say things like even if
a person isn't white when they're doing
something that favors the system of the
patriarchy they are acting as a white
supremacist they're acting in the stead
of whiteness and now with all this going
on of course it's all Russians even ones
who have absolutely nothing to do with
the conflict even though most of them
living in the country had absolutely no
ability to make any decision whether or
not Ukraine was was going to be invaded
yeah exactly they're they're all being
slapped with this label and in the same
way uh in the same way that you often
see black political commentators who
happen to be conservative labeled as
white or white supremacists I agree with
with uh Lydia that we're going to see
people being labeled as Russian or
Russian agency I now now or at the very
least that that's very you've got to
look back at history to see what will
happen now that we can consider to be a
rhyme history doesn't repeat in crimes
so
um what could happen now well phrasing
of bank accounts already seen it yep yep
suspension of of uh accounts through
through other uh like like Airbnb and
things like that other services being
totally removed from social media they
have put a label on Rachel Blevins this
is creepy stuff maybe they'll change
Russian State Affiliated media she
doesn't work there anymore Twitter
should remove it immediately Lee Camp
having his personal podcast deleted
for Simply Having worked for RT in a
separate capacity it was completely
deleted off on Spotify Spotify does he
have cop backups oh it's on YouTube as
well YouTube hasn't taken it down but
this is this is where it starts getting
really creepy uh creepy where they're
basically going to start labeling people
as like lessers or
um it's like the others they're gonna
say are you an other was that a black
mirror episode what was that movie or
was that TV show remember do you
remember I don't know if you guys
remember that one where people are like
are you an other I think I think yeah it
was a movie yeah where some guy is like
you know here's on TV a politician say
something about I don't want to repeat
it because YouTube I I know what you're
talking I think um I think I passed in
and out of the room as you guys were
watching this it wasn't Black Mirror but
it was a similar Anthology yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah what was it Creep Show
maybe or something I don't know I don't
know but it's like the TV on a
politician says something about like all
others are bad it's like some new TV and
literally says very on the nose channel
is it channel uh zero maybe I don't know
I watch a bunch of these weird sci-fi
things and then he goes around he's like
what was that the other day when they're
talking about the others and they're
like why do you care are you another and
he goes no no I just saw that and like
what is that about and they were like
you're not defending others are you and
he was like no no I just don't
understand and then eventually the more
he started asking questions about why
you're demonizing others they said you
must be another and he sees like a woman
running on the street screaming help and
they're just beating the crap out of her
and he's like why are you doing that and
they're like she's an other and he's
like well stop hitting her I'm like you
must be an other too that's where we're
going Russians
they're going to ban you they're going
to shut you down they're going to put a
label on you let me correct myself
Christina's Motion Picture Association
oh they're gonna make sure
they are going to make you wear a tag on
your social media profiles identifying
you as Russian State Affiliated media
and 30 years ago Seinfeld did that skit
with the AIDS ribbon
that's right hey I marched I marched I
don't want to wear the ribbon who who
does not want to wear the ribbon I know
that's where we are now so we were at
the at the um the state of the union and
it's and by the way you know I look at
that stuff and I saw there was like a
photo op that they did with this like
American Ukrainian flag thing
I hate that so you're defacing our flag
that by the way that is a defacement
that's actually the you have changed the
face of the flag that's where the word
defacement comes from uh of the flag
itself
um in order to do that so you're not
actually going to do anything for the
people of Ukraine you you sold them all
this all these weapons and you provoked
Russia you talked about them joining
NATO so you lied to them about that and
you sold them as false promise now that
Russia is pissed off they're attacking
you
um they've gone completely insane so
they're shelling cities at this point
they're using artillery on cities and
Russia's not going to stop because this
is how Russia fights
um and in the meanwhile instead of you
know actually helping the Ukrainian
people that you promised you're not
going to do that but you're gonna hold
photo ops and you're going to put on
lapel pins and put up hashtags as if
that's actually going to stop anywhere
the show is electric dreams thank you
for waffles yeah electric James awesome
show by the way that episode seriously I
talked about before you guys should
watch it's the last episode it's an
anthology series I thought it was
absolutely fantastic uh can I ask the
authorization of people yeah can I ask
something here
um does does Twitter do this with people
who are affiliated with State media
generally speaking or are they only
doing this to people affiliated with
Russian State media I think that it was
Chinese State media okay but do they do
it to the BBC no or the CBC Indian State
media that's a great Point there's a lot
of Indians NPR
well I think what does NPR get like a
microscopic Force yeah or Al Jazeera
small percent all of Al Jazeera is owned
by the Qatari government yeah
Al Jazeera plus all the rest well you
know the amazing thing was about the
demonization of Russia Today which
always confused me was that Al Jazeera
Plus
pushed the exact same opinions as RT for
the most part for the most part yeah and
it was funded by by the Qatari
government yet it was never demonized
and I was confused by this it was clear
the issue was the nation of Russia and
not the propaganda of you know of it's
not the messaging of what they're doing
it's the fact that Russia owns it so if
if another channel is state owned and
does the literally the same thing
promoting the exact same things of
course I just find it very interesting
that the elite in the ruling class have
absolutely no problem with information
being imported into our country that's
going to destabilize our Unity as a
country it just bothers them on the
basis of who's doing it yo they're so
yeah because they're the only ones who
want to be able to do exactly exactly
it's useful to them I want to see Joe
Biden come out and say president
zielinski you have our support but you
must condemn the azov Battalion we will
not tolerate neo-nazism
I want to see him stand by his campaign
message about white nationalism and
white supremacy and offer up his support
to zelenski and Ukraine but in but
condemn the neo-nazis of the azerbate
Tim didn't you know the entire reason
Joe Biden decided to run for president
with Charlottesville that's he's
literally been on the record saying that
that's the entire reason he decided to
run for president so why isn't he saying
something about this yeah weird no joke
uh Magic Nawaz on the show us and I was
really trying to hammer this one home
this is so what's happening is people
from around the world are going to
Ukraine to fight with the azov and then
they're getting radicalized and then
when this is done what he sees happening
or what he fears is that they're going
to go back home for newly radicalized
and with all this military training now
and then spread this Nazism around the
world it's it's the mujahideen all over
again it's it's going to be like the
Syrian rebels to Isis you are going to
have these people go there be
radicalized fight for an ideology and
then maintain that or you're going to
empower people of radical ideology with
military training and capable abilities
and we know where that goes but I tell
you this man history Rhymes the U.S
continually does this and it's almost
like they like doing it it's good for
whatever it is or I shouldn't say the US
the West Halliburton yeah the military
industrial complex for sure well and we
know how it works anyone who can be even
tangentially associated with the right
is uh a person who we can blame the
entirety of the conservative movement
for every single thing that they do so
they're constantly conflating regular
conservatives with the far right with
Nazis Etc and so if there are these
attacks if Majid's prediction comes true
and I think it's a very interesting and
compelling one then what's going to
happen is you will have neo-nazis
engaging in violence more often because
they'll have acquired combat experience
and then what's going to happen is
they're going to say look at the rise in
far-right violence now we need to censor
regular run-of-the-mill conservatives
because it was them who radicalized
people by pushing them down these rabbit
holes which turned them into Nazis it's
also an excuse to ramp up federal
military police when you have internal
strife like Nazism
we all know about the office of
censorship in the United States
the office of censorship was an
emergency wartime agency agency set up
in the U.S from December 19 1941 to Aid
in the censorship of all Communications
coming into and out of the United States
including its territories in the
Philippines the efforts of the office
office of censorship to balance the
protection of sensitive War related
information with the Constitutional
freedoms of the press is considered
largely successful largely successful oh
it was amazing thank you Wikipedia for
telling us about the successful office
of censorship it's just loose lips
the fact is look at that thanks Ike the
sensors
why would we not see the same thing in a
World War III scenario or even let's
maybe wouldn't even call it world war
three maybe we enter into full-scale war
with just Russia alone and and NATO why
would we not see this same effort of
well we saw this effort with with kovitz
exactly I was just about to say didn't
we have the Biden Administration
pressuring social media companies to
remove information that they consider to
be misinformation but I'm saying
escalate to the next degree the FCC
commissioner nominee uh who who is up I
can't remember her name right now but
they're trying to block it this is
exactly her position we just saw we just
went through two years of understanding
what it was
that the amount of people the you know
the critical mass amount of people would
go along with and they ratcheted things
up and they ratcheted things up in the
name of crisis in the name of National
Emergency and they just got had a huge
system-wide test of everything that that
they could roll out without seeing any
meaningful pushback whatsoever and in
Canada they're about a year ahead of us
and you know what I'll add this to him
maybe this is a little bit of a black
pill here but I don't think we'd have
another office of censorship because we
don't need one yeah we already have
Google exactly they just flip a switch
you're done or alphabet rather it's even
more terrifying they have like 13
companies which are like AI we are the
alphabet alphabet is the name of the
company it's funny because we also have
the alphabet agencies right it's not all
coincidence
yeah they were probably like it's like
let's we're kind of like one of those
alphabet companies and they're like yeah
we are alphabet we'll just call
ourselves alphabet they're you know
I wonder if Google was you know doing
all this really great work and they were
like don't be evil guys and then some
you know D uh some uh bureaucratic
administrative State walk guy walks in
and says we're taking over and the first
thing we got to do is guys that that
slogan don't be evil we're evil come on
that's the new model that they were
trying to get rid of a double negative
when you say don't be evil you people
hear evil evil evil and then they just
start thinking it and be but when you
write it and you read it it interacts
with your brain differently than when
you hear it no Ian they're just evil
it's just that might be true too I mean
there's different people that own the
company now yeah like Larry and Sergey
were pretty cool but man did that thing
get out of here are they still in
alphabet though partially I just saw
that uh Sergey sold a bunch of stock
last July I think maybe it was Larry one
of them sold like I don't know how many
millions of dollars worth of stock they
want to control what you think they need
to Rally people behind this this is why
they got so triggered when I said I
despise appeals to emotion because I'm
directly calling out what is very
obvious propaganda crying translators
yep no no hold on there a minute man the
job of a translator is to translate why
would you hire someone or keep someone
on the job if they're crying you'd be
like I said before you'd be like oh no
he's crying let's get him into the break
room and have some coffee and take a
breath and get someone else in there who
can do their job you know and because
it's manipulation it's a follow-up of
what you said Sheamus like we don't
really need an office of censorship they
close the office of censorship in 1945
when the war ended but basically then
they started the liberal economic order
within like eight months and I think
they just winded in all that censorship
ability into this new spy network of
five eyes or you know the global
military industrial well I mean it's
interesting because
for a long time you had what was it the
three and then the five major networks
that everyone got all of their
information from and that was wonderful
for them because it was very easy to
control what people were seeing and
hearing and then the internet popped up
and now it seemed as if there was a
threat people could get their
information from everywhere but uh
fortunately for them and unfortunately
for the us a lot of that power has been
Consolidated and we're not quite back in
the same position but in some ways we're
getting there I'm I'm optimistic on some
level that we won't quite be able to get
back to that but at the end of the day
it doesn't really matter if people are
too scared to speak the truth and most
seem to be yeah self-censorship is as
effective as as you know forceful
censorship in a way yeah well it's
interesting there have been studies
which have suggested that people are
better capable or would prefer to endure
physical pain over social rejection wow
yeah uh and it's psychological suffering
well I know psychological suffering in
general and so if if people if people
feel as if they are being rejected by
the group or they fear being rejected by
the group for stating something they're
going to be very likely to keep quiet in
the same way that they'd be likely to
keep quiet if they thought someone would
physically aggress upon them for
speaking out so this is the Stasi got
into towards the you know everybody you
watch the lives of others
um one of the greatest movies on on
communist surveillance systems and the
programs that they had people informing
each other in East Germany so that was
the 1960s by the 1970s 1980s the Stasi
wasn't running these massive
surveillance programs anymore and they
weren't running these massive
incarceration programs the way they do
it depicted in that film what they ended
up doing was they realized that if you
were a dissident if you were someone
who's a troublemaker they had a problem
with you uh it's exactly what Shane was
just laying out first thing we would do
is start to ostracize you and then they
would start to shame you they would
smear you in the media they would drag
your name through the mud they would
essentially Blacklist you and they would
make it so that the social shame upon
everyone else of even associating with
you would be enough to destroy you and
it was actually much cheaper and far
more effective than throwing you in
prison and making a potential martyr of
you how I I I I I I I I wonder about
this like how is a show like this
possible in these you know we're
literally saying that partly because
it's a group of Us wing in a prayer
haven't you haven't you had the SWAT
team come like five times yeah I mean
two I mean six I mean so how is it
possible it is possible for now but look
at the forces look at the forces trying
to shut it down I still feel like we're
in the Prelude you know yeah I think a
lot of it has to do with enough people a
big group a large enough group of people
communicating these ideas makes it hard
to stop the idea if it's one person
alone in their room on a webcam then you
know yeah get swatted you know and
that's why I go answer that's why when I
see censorship you know I do speak out
against it even if it's something I
don't particularly agree with or don't
particularly like or support you know
the idea that one person or one entity
just has this ability to to blank it
wipe out all Communications right that's
actually a much bigger issue than some
idiot on a podcast that I don't listen
to yeah the vulnerability of our system
isn't talked about enough from Comet
strikes to floods to earthquakes to
volcanic super eruptions to just uh just
a power outage from a solar flare or
like a or like uh well you're seeing
these for example you're seeing these
stories that so Google and Apple pay
have are shut down in Russia and so
suddenly because they went cashless now
people are saying wait how do I get on
the subway how do I pay for things in
stores how do I do this and so we've
outsourced all you know if you're signed
up for all these things now you're
Outsourcing your very ability to
function in society to Silicon Valley so
that gives them that I mean this we're
talking about Sovereign power we can
artificial
we can never go cashless we can never go
I mean that has to be within our our DNA
as like a fight to the death we can
never be compatible so you think we need
a federal some sort of federal power
that Danes that currency valuable I
think you need a physical even not
necessarily cash but I think we have to
have a system that you can have a
physical commodity that I can hide under
my bed because if if Jack doesn't like
me and he's able to call the guys who
are on Apple pay and say shut down his
account if I can't go to the grocery
store if I can buy things if my credit
quote unquote is stuck in my phone and
my phone is useless because Jack doesn't
like me that I'm I'm a powerless I have
no agency left you're lucky I like you
you're lucky I want to add a caveat to
something I said earlier I wanted to
pull up information about what I
referenced um what what I was
referencing it's not a study about
social rejection versus physical pain
there's there's two articles I'm looking
at here but basically the idea is that
um they have shown that we process
social pain in the same part of the
brain that we process physical pain with
and um there's also a very interesting
perspective from uh psychology and
psychologists I I'm not sure if it's the
consensus or not but basically that
emotional pain is in many ways worse
than physical pain because it can be
triggered by memories in a way that
physical pain cannot so for example I
can remember something from the past
that hurt me or was difficult for me and
uh the emotional trauma of that can sort
of return whereas if I remember a
physical injury I'm not going to
literally feel that physical pain in
quite the same way wow yeah emotional
pain can make you like adopt a posture
which can then bring on a certain sort
of tension leading to injury unless you
dream have you ever dreamed had a dream
where you have physical pain and you
wake up and like something hurts oh yeah
something all the time interesting yeah
all the time if you're on a dream and
you want to get out close your eyes
really tight till they hurt and then
when you open them you'll be awake the
pain getting some so I found an account
that has some backstory on how this
nuclear power plant situation uh started
so apparently they're saying that and
again caveat caveat caveat right fog of
War fog of War Grand it's all blah blah
blah that they're saying that the
Russians rolled up and demanded that the
power plants surrender and that the
Defenders of the plants surrender
um they said we have overwhelming Force
you should surrender you should stand
down so that we can take over this plant
and do so peacefully The Defenders
refused and that's when the firefight
started wow so those were Russian
soldiers on the ground it was Russian
soldiers on the ground and it looked
like they were Defenders and if you look
at that clip
um that a few people have have pulled
out of that live stream it looks like
you can actually see Tracer fire rounds
being fired from the roof at the Russian
Artillery okay
and then so that was our incoming
artillery
well the artillery is on the ground
right next to the the power plant
yes oh are they firing that artillery at
the power plant across the street well
at the Defenders wow that close range
yes wow that's yeah that's what you're
seeing in in the video okay I thought
stuff was coming from out and then I
thought I saw missiles flying outward
from there but that wasn't what I was no
those are just shells okay
so we actually just watched a battle
take place in real time yes we did
that's kind of amazing yes we actually
did I remember the modern Siege even a
couple modern
um Feats of social media the first was
when the alcazam brigades in Palestine
were firing Rockets into Israel and the
IDF and the Oxnard brigades were
tweeting at each other in a flame War
yeah during a hot War literally and a
lot of people actually laughing because
it was like you know alcazam was like we
will wipe you out and the IDF was like
try it we'll stop you and I'm like
they're tweeting at each other but then
there was um in the Middle East
we got a video a GoPro attached to a to
a tank to um uh to it to a tank and uh
the soldiers who were shooting back at
it or being fired upon were also they
also had GoPros and so the footage made
it to the internet where researchers
were able to find both perspectives and
put it in a single video where you could
see both sides of a conflict online
crazy stuff yeah because you hear both
the voices of the people from either
side you couldn't hear anything from the
tank because the camera's outside and
the people are inside but you could hear
the people on there well have you seen
the the chechins and the azov leaders
are now sending or cutting videos about
each other uh talking about essentially
how they're gearing up for this massive
fight in Mario poll wow and so those are
kind of you're considered your most
brutal fighters on either side I mean
and for azov I mean you can find very
quickly uh videos of as of committing
beheadings committing crucifixions of
ethnic Russians uh chechens I think goes
without saying um extremely extremely
brutal or if you know anything about the
Battle of grozny or the Chechen Wars and
and so the leaders of carterov who is
the leader of the chechens is now coming
into he's Pro Putin fighting for the
Russians going in specifically targeting
that as of Battalion and the last some
of the messages I was getting
from a contact that I have that's uh
active duty right now was that they were
you know possibly trying to get as of to
at least surrender and they were saying
hey if you we just want the city we
don't need we don't need to kill all of
you just leave and we'll let you go out
to the West well you can go to Levy we
won't even you know we will let you
surrender and just just evacuate and of
course as I was saying no we saw video
as of a member of the Battalion dipping
bullets and pigs lard right and then
saying we're gonna get because a lot of
checkers are Muslim and uh that's also
very concerning because
religion into it which from UFC the
Habib yeah he's like a governor isn't he
a mayor or something no I'm thinking of
a there's a thing of the two brothers
right yeah there's an MMA fighter that's
like a a mayor of a city in Russia right
now Russia Klitschko Klitschko that's
that's that's Ukraine that's Ukraine no
that's no that's yeah that's and they're
boxers that's completely oh yeah I got
it a third right thanks no no fighters
of some sort there's somewhere I
remember him being you should write
species
the Iranian people they're still by the
way I noticed you guys mentioned called
it a uh uh State of the Union I can't in
good faith it's a campaign speech uh at
the end he did say the State of the
Union was strong and it's strong because
the people are strong strong technically
you could argue it was a state of the
union because you know very end nobody's
actually nobody's even questioning why
Putin is doing this now have you noticed
that yeah yeah everyone kind of gets it
so that's so true that narrative isn't
even the narrative is okay you can ask
why is he doing this right and I think
there's a lot of
clearly huge debate on that and he's not
been very clear about it in some ways
you know he has the stated purposes but
we think there's probably some more than
that but nobody's asking why now
everybody kind of gets it yeah this this
is the time well he actually so what
happened was Biden pulled him aside and
really intimidated him uh and made it
very clear that there would be
repercussions if he tried to uh take the
hearts and minds of the Iranian people
and so I couldn't said all right I won't
did he whisper he's here
I I want to mention this too uh Ian um
your point about it being more of like a
campaign speech I completely agree which
is why we we just released a cartoon
about this today for for Freedom Tunes
if you guys want to check that out just
want to plug that because that's um very
much along those lines when he said he
was going to help Kira what do you say
was gonna cure he said we're going to
end cancer as we know it what are you
talking about as We Know
he's just going to change the definition
of the word sure he's like so I
fulfilled my promise called up Miriam
Webster and said you know put another
word in there and now it's different as
we know it different words
he was talking about astrology Cancer
he's talking about these people oh man I
just can't stand the camera I think so
when I think people who hate Trump and
there's those people who dislike him I
think when they would hear Trump tell a
story I can imagine what their reaction
was like this guy he's so full of
himself he's such a needy blah blah blah
when Biden told that story I looked at
Putin and I said I don't think you have
a soul and he looked at me and said we
understand each other did anyone believe
that that actually happened
so Trump tells a story and they're over
the top and they're silly Biden tells
the story and even his supporters are
like yeah dude that didn't happen was a
bad thing
NBC interview with Putin they asked him
about that and he was like I I don't I
don't remember it was a diplomacy thing
so he insulted me like that I don't know
why I did that that's just like a weird
thing to say and it's like Vladimir
Putin was banging the razor Blood on the
curb
his nuclear weapon on the curb get it
Rusty put it in a barrel well also like
call them Esther Williams or something
I just I I find it hilarious that with
Trump
Trump is like if you judge the Ukraine I
will nuke Moscow like a very real
concrete threat and Biden's like you
don't have a soul man
okay but it's like
okay
let's take Ukraine now okay it's like oh
no Joe Biden will not like me if I do
this who's like I've never had a soul
I'm glad you recognize that Putin like
Biden says that you ain't got a soul man
then he walks away and Putin confused
looks over to like Sergey lavrov and
says he says I have no soul and he goes
yes
do you think like what an unbelievably
insane thing for him to ever even if he
did say that do you think that um do you
think that somebody on the international
stage wants their enemy to think they
have a soul do you want to be seen as a
bleeding heart type no no I mean Biden
does no yeah exactly it's just so
ridiculous is everyone's like oh this is
so bad for public relations people will
think I am not nice guy yeah you also
would make a a good like which actually
would be the down downfall of Putin
inside of Russia people didn't think he
was a nice guy but he was a nice guy
comic would be like Trump saying I'll
nuke Moscow and Putin looking to lavrov
and being like let's hold back for a
minute then Biden saying you have no
soul and he'll be like okay we're good
no it's only like Trump gives a direct
threat of violence and Bud's like you're
mean man don't attack me in my
vulnerable spots which are here here and
here he's like hey man if you're really
mean if you did Biden actually did that
yeah he's like you ain't got a soul man
so I'm gonna show you a list of all the
places you better not attack there you
go just that one's most important I
trust you
that's crazy man it's a fundamental risk
misreading of this you know and you can
dig into some of the philosophical
aspects of this where you know when you
look at the United States in in many
ways at least in terms of how our regime
is positioned you know we are it's it's
Athens and Sparta right so we are the
sea power you know we want Commerce we
want trade we want these sort of
globalized rules we want to be able to
do business with the rest of the world
whereas Russia
predominantly is a land power they are a
land-based power we were just talking
earlier about how they have so many
issues for them to be able to uh get to
see so they have that that mindset of
strength over everything
um power over everything might makes
right
um and it does have a deeper sense of
cultural traditionalism whereas in the
U.S it is this more you know sort of
progress you know small P progressivism
of this enlightened oh we can always be
better we can rise above right these are
two very these are two ideas that are in
not only philosophical contention but
spiritual contention as well and I think
if we fail to understand that we are
completely misreading the situation not
only and Bill roggio had a great article
about how we've completely misread
Russia's strategy in the war I think
that's obvious but at this point right
Russia isn't losing just because they
didn't take Kiev in the first 24 hours
but I think we completely misread the
way Russian leaders are even just even
the way that they think so if you can't
understand how or appreciate how your
adversary thinks how can you ever
attempt to get ahead of their decisions
like well get inside their ooda Loops or
even predict their future moves it's so
true Lauren southern made a great point
about this yesterday when referring to
China two days ago we have no idea how
the Chinese think that they know exactly
how we think because they go to the U.N
and say the United States of America is
racist and they don't care about black
lives I know China doesn't care about
minorities China uh in order to sell the
the new Star Wars film in China they had
to reduce the size of a black actor on
the poster they don't care yeah I get
messages from time time from Chinese
citizens that are like uh CCP is not
China and so if you really want to
understand Chinese read the Romance of
the Three Kingdoms or watch the movie
and then read the book yeah but I think
I think I know what you're saying and I
agree with you 100 but I would go even a
little further
in the in right now in America it is not
just like we have a small P
progressivism it was not long ago that
the American flag on a Nike sneaker
caused uproars yeah right so not only do
we not have we have a progressivism we
are intentionally led by this
Administration quite frankly or the
progressive left we are intentionally
destroying the pillars of our foundation
yeah and the smallest things and we've
talked a lot about this on the show the
smallest things that unify us like like
the national anthem well you should be
able to protest that and this little
moment while that should be up for
debate and the the George Washington
maybe we should change the name of the
school so I think if you're Putin and
and this is not uh you know Shilling for
him at all don't get me wrong but if you
are him and his administration and and
Russian power and you look at the west
and say they don't even respect their
George Washington right why why are we
afraid of these people right like we
changed the name of of Abraham Lincoln
School in California do you think but do
you think maybe it's possible that
jijian ping feels threatened by how
introspective we are no doubt and how
diverse our army is yeah that was it
wait till he sees our diversity exactly
oh
yeah all of our soldiers are doing
Tick-Tock videos that's why Russia
invaded Russia saw the threat of the
West diversity trainings and he was
sweating bullets and he was like we have
to invade let's do this too yeah once
they all once they all learn about
diversity inclusivity and Equity we're
done now what you're seeing is so we've
we've become quite decadent in in this
sort of 30 years since the fall of the
Soviet Union this idea of fukiyama's you
know end of history and everyone's going
to adopt so instead of thinking that our
values were western or that they were
derived from the Bible
um that they're you know Greco-Roman
legal practice European law Etc
principles Enlightenment what you all of
that no no we decided that these were
Universal principles and that we could
go on these nation building projects
around the world and that we could
impose our way of thinking on everyone
because our way of thinking was natural
and we don't even need all this history
as you're describing to back it up that
we've you know that we've Advanced from
or that we've developed from no no no no
no these are just the universe of values
and our job now is to prostilatize the
world and evangelicalize them to our way
of thinking so the first place of course
that we're going to try that is
Afghanistan right because you know we're
going to turn you know Kandahar into
California and we never once sat back
and thought you know maybe the rest of
the world doesn't want those things or
maybe they don't think that way and so
that's why you're seeing now instead of
actually focusing on the things that
would make our country strong like
energy strong currency we do need a
strong US Dollar by the way if the US
dollar falls off its perch that's really
going to be bad for a lot of Americans
because I think a lot of the people out
there that are living paycheck to
paycheck that don't have a lot of
savings you know you always see those
studies out there and I'm sure it's much
worse now about how many people have
less than you know five thousand dollars
two thousand dollars in their checking
accounts
um what happens to them when that
checking account becomes you completely
worthless overnight because the US
dollar loses its World Reserve status
they'll print like another 8 trillion
and try and just give everyone four
grand to get so you're seeing you're
seeing now a complete reworking of the
world order and that's why even as
horrific as these scenes are that are
coming out of Ukraine
um the long-term implications of this
might actually be worse yeah because
unipolarity is gone the international
rules-based order is gone multi-polarity
is returning that's going to be a huge
problem for us because remember even you
know we talk about the Swift system okay
let's you know pull the nuclear plan and
kick Russia off the Swift system well
the Swift system only works because it's
backed by the US dollar if Russia is
already planning to get off the dollar
then they don't need it yeah well isn't
it interesting oh no no please no no no
well it's interesting how we like to
play philanthropists and act like we are
exporting Western values around the
world and helping people live better
lives because we care about the the
downtrodden one in many circumstances
it's either militaristic intervention or
economic bullying to force our way of
life onto other people even in country
is where they're not ready for it or
ready for it is the wrong term because
some of the things that we try to
important to these countries aren't
things people should ever be ready for I
find it fascinating and I don't think
it's a coincidence that the intellectual
founders of neoconservatism were former
marxists and look at the neoconservative
mission look at what we try to do in
Afghanistan
oh we're going to completely and
fundamentally restructure a culture at
the barrel of a gun and this country
this entire nation with a history that
we don't even care to understand is
going to Bow before the order we have
determined is the culmination of History
which is how they conceptualize
democracy now instead of Marxism as
neoconservatives because we ordered them
to at the barrel of a gun and were able
to restructure their thinking it's crazy
dude I watched I don't even want to get
I was looking at a picture of the bath
party so that didn't work by the way and
you just see these young Frat Boys it's
too long of a conversation to go to now
check it out though Saddam Hussein bath
party image and you see Saddam is a
young rambunctious if that guy was a nut
well the thing that I find bizarre about
this whole conversation from the 30 000
foot level especially are we invading do
we not invade what is the role of NATO
et cetera Etc it was not very long ago
that like a million and a half hutus and
Tutsis in Rwanda slaughtered each other
with the machete and and the West just
sat there and watched it and said wow
that's bad I mean like literally over a
million five hundred thousand and the
majority of them were hacked to death
and we just sat there and were like with
Chinese machines that's bad but there
was so I don't understand uh should
should we intervene when there is evil
happening as a philosophy I understand
that position but but we're ready to
jump into the Ukraine but no one wanted
to go to Rwanda so what's the difference
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
nuke the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show if you really
like it and head over to timcast.com
become a member because we're gonna have
a members only segment up around 11 or
so p.m where we go into more details on
conflict crisis and Other Stories so you
this is where we're going to be a bit
more crass and uh uh it's the uncensored
show but let's read some of these super
chats we have this from Scarlett
Johansen Scarlett wait what am I no
Scarlett johansi okay Tim what advice do
you have for me I want to go undercover
and report on the ground I know it's
dangerous what should I bring with me I
have no advice for you other than don't
go you don't do that yeah don't
um in order to enter conflict zones of
this degree you need a lot more
experience so um have you seen the
Reddit threads by the way of people like
I'm going there's a whole red subreddit
of I think it's Ukraine volunteers or
something people one guy was like and
I'm sure there's trolls in there of
course but one guy was like hey are you
allowed to bring weed into Ukraine
because I have this bong that I got but
I don't want to break it it's got
residues these stories maybe those
people should go yeah
basically like this if if you have to
ask a question on the internet to
somebody else about whether or not I
should go don't go or join the military
I don't know from your advice if
someone's questioning go help refugees
if you want to go and do something good
right now and you don't have that
training go to Poland right now help out
with the refugees send money to the
Charities that are then the ngos that
are trying to be there there's a lot of
people
you know Scarlett Joe says go undercover
the uh
that sounds like a death please don't
try to go undercover yeah because no
just do not do that yeah undercover is
if if you are not easily identifiable
you look like an enemy combatant yeah or
your spot period a spy or a risk
especially someone not from Ukraine if
you're walking around they they need
only do one thing a guy in a military
suit Will shout out a sentence in
Russian or Ukrainian and when you go uh
spy that's it right there so I had this
happen when I was in Ukraine oh I love
this too The Young Turks were like smack
talking me because they just love
talking about me you live rent free up
there buddy I mean with real estate
prices right now you can't be I
appreciate the pr they give me but I
love the commenter what do you mean
their channels so much I mean how many
thousand views okay put their name in
people's minds and people were uh
commenting like I'd love to see what Tim
would do if he was in Ukraine I was like
I was there when this was starting in
2014 when they were ousting Yanukovych
were you there people as it happened I
was not there as they asked I'd left
just before that wow but I was there as
they were building the barricades and
the Soviet the Soviet General who came
in and like they was in a tent it was
cool to talk to the guy I didn't speak
Ukrainian or Russian but we had a
translator and simply walking in I got
surrounded by a bunch of ukrainians
yelling at me and my and my the guy's
working with me and I was just like
American journalist and then someone
came and intervened and started speaking
to them in Ukrainian and then they made
the way and let us in they liked Journey
what is under beanie show us what is
under beanie I just understand this the
the maidan protest they called it Euro
maidan they were very pro-west so when
they heard American journalists was
there they were like this is what we
need to get support from the West we
need Americans here and so they were
like oh oh this is exciting but it was
ridiculously dangerous they were sniper
fire people were getting shot not that I
was not there for that I had left I had
come back and I was fortunately not
there when it got really bad with the
molotovs but I I got I got to go and
witness the uh the collapsed lens statue
people had like taken fragments of the
statue they took his head in his mind
wow people I got to go into a Ukrainian
government building that had been
totally seized and occupied and
ransacked so that was that was by the
way
the only the only coup that was worse
than that of course was January 6. yeah
yeah but I want to stress okay in
history the coup were like I want to
stress this point
by the time I had left and I had had
devolved into like full-scale urban
conflict I was not there why I am not
going to pre I am not a war reporter I
do civil and urban conflict which means
up until that point I was like that's my
limit I've been on the ground in
numerous countries I rode in the back of
this truck in Thailand during the yellow
shirt you know red shirt the monarchist
and parliamentarian protests and there
were blood stains on the ground because
someone in a motorcycle drove by and
threw a grenade into it we got in it
after they scrubbed it clean and then we
rode down the street wearing body armor
and helmets like these are the vehicles
that get attacked that was the extent to
my capabilities in a conflict Zone when
it comes to what's happening now in
Ukraine I don't have the experience the
skill nor the courage to be in a fire
fight which and by the way if if you're
thinking I mean I shouldn't even say
this but if you're thinking I'm gonna go
by myself right right you're already
yeah just and Hall you're already wrong
right you are not going to be go going
you're and not only that by the way
you're not going to be a help to
yourself or others you're going to be a
detriment to others you're going to be
detriment to people you're trying to
help you're going to be a hindrance and
you are going to get probably yourself
killed and a lot of other people killed
if they're trying to save you no no your
limits man their limits so disability so
look my and by the way and I'm just
going to say this I'm that telling
people to go and throw Molotov cocktails
and run up in civilian clothes against a
professional military with with a
mechanized armored vehicles with 14
millimeter 30 millimeter cannons right
we've you've seen the videos right now
I'm sure we've all seen the videos now
where the the entire tree people tried
to hide behind trees because they
thought this was like a Marvel movie or
something and that the trees would
protect you from cannon fire no it's not
gonna work everyone was killed right
just understand where you are there's a
reason depleted uranium rounds you know
that I don't know about that but there's
a reason why I stayed only in UK rain
for so long before leaving there's a
reason why I can I can do what people
some people criticize as parachute
journalism to an extent when it came to
the high like high-level Warfare the
journalists that go in after me speak
five languages they're fluent in Russian
they're fluent in Polish they're fluent
in Ukrainian and several other you know
romance languages as well so they go on
the ground and they can communicate with
anyone who approaches them and they
probably have a network of them alive
they probably already have a network
established right I mean they had plans
for this and they have safe houses these
are these are people yeah so the
journalists that you know eventually
they go in that I remain in
communication with as I leave these are
people who have already lived in the
region they've lived there for two or
three years or they're from there that
the like when you see a reporter on the
ground there are corporate
I don't like these these kinds of
journalists that have like big security
Crews they go into secured zones and
then just talk to the camera it's fine
okay that's not what I'm referring to
but actual War correspondence when when
I went to Thailand I was sent with a guy
who lived in Thailand for five years and
spoke Thai they were like it's you know
we're in this this lull period where we
can have you go in and produce an
English-speaking like experience of
what's going on if it gets too hot you
come back out we keep our crews on the
ground who are War correspondents
trained with with high-powered rifles
with body armor military tactics a lot
of the journalists that go on the ground
in these situations are former military
as well people need to understand that
it's not these these people on Reddit
who are like we're going it's like that
itch I don't know after Vietnam has
there been any legit work correspondence
from the United States press Corps like
you put the body cameras on troops and
you want to show the reality of what
they're going for I mean
in in that movie the Iraq war in Syria
the first you certainly I remember there
was Ryan
Michael Hastings let's read some more
Super chats though we've got uh MJ says
I work in nuclear as long as they don't
hit the reactor uh building coolant
Supply pumps or the off-site power lines
they will be able to stabilize the
reactors with no risk of meltdown well
there you go we got let's see is this
Dan Brockman says Tim the Collision of
ammo in that pig lard video is far more
likely uh it's far more likely it's five
uh 5.45 by 39 not 762 by 39 study the
AK-74 you silly man love y'all oh I
stand corrected
you see you see the video yeah did you
do you see what kind of ammo if you
spread that face I didn't look all I saw
was what it looked like and I assumed it
was 7 16. misinformation I mean that is
the predominant round that you're going
to see in this in the seven six two
three seven six two with AKs yeah yeah
right that's what I thought I thought
they were using AKs but some he said
AK-74 so that uses the smaller round uh
uh some variants if it do Yeah man so
it's funny when I show people but let's
I love showing people bullets because
you ask them which one's the weapon of
war and I'll show like I'll show a
polymer tip 450 Bushmaster which is huge
and then I'll show like a nine
millimeter Luger or something and then
they're just like oh and they point to
the big one every time but sometimes
some people are like you're tricking me
it must be the small one and I'm like
yeah you know why you can carry more of
them right like Hunters go out with like
three you know three rounds of 450. what
if the deer is wearing Kevlar you said
that again oh man wait who said that
Biden oh good for him that's brilliant
well then I'll call Jim eagle and uh
we'll go to the Field of Dreams and get
130 from Pat but don't forget uh Binger
explosive tip hollow points for hunting
all right
let's grab Super Chat here
my my contacts are getting all dressed
it's gonna be hard hard for me to read
come on man Clayton Johnston says as
someone who has worked a few outage out
outages and new plants the transmission
substation would be a main and and
likely the primary target in a power
plant unless they are attempting to
cause a meltdown bad idea to fight there
unless they want to
GBP says if the narrative that Putin
wants the USSR back is true it wouldn't
make sense for him to attack the most
valuable and volatile infrastructure
ruin the land and then cause yourself
further problems
that's true too and that's why
um
if you could win a war without firing a
shot propaganda and influence you would
so uh you know you know my view on this
is the west and Russia are already at
War they're just the West is playing a
propaganda influence war and Russia's in
a third generational hot conflict so
Russia clearly was losing they knew it
they said time for bolts the West is
like we're we're not gonna go and fight
but they use every manipulative cyber
tactic in the book to try and win and
what happens the children of Russian
politicians and oligarchs are begging
for the war to end when you also see
that the U.S victory the U.S is
providing and I I don't think this comes
a surprise but you know I think it's
been publicly acknowledged now I saw
Zero the article the U.S is providing
real-time intelligence to Kiev wait you
said oh here we go these children want
the war to end these are these are the
hot models of Instagram children
government officials Russia that part I
had missed earlier okay I know they were
calling for it to end that's yeah they
were saying we don't support this we
don't we don't want war no war all that
stuff
so it used to be people you say well
it's neither because it's Cyrillic yeah
that's true people used to say the
Ukraine but um it's just you no it's
Ukraine which means the Borderland yeah
I catch myself Ukraine a lot and I'm
wondering where I got this so so the
root of that is granitza which me which
means border so ukrania is at the border
so or you know interpreted would be the
Borderlands so if you're speaking in
Ukrainian or or Russian or polish you're
saying the Borderlands but go to Ukraine
and say the Ukraine and see their
reaction yeah no they just correct you
because it's like no we're not the we're
just Ukraine it's a country say Ukraine
did this Ukraine the Ukraine did this
the Netherlands or the Hague there's a
couple of us the Bronx the United States
yeah so it's like these United States
I don't think there's anything England I
don't think there was any
um you know any negative connotation by
calling it the Ukraine it was just sort
of it's racist it's just right the idea
but they're all the same race
but I am Slavic so I can say it listen
and learn it's racist what I was told by
people in Ukraine was that by calling it
the Ukraine you were saying the people
who live on the border as opposed to
their national identity of ukrainians so
saying Ukraine does this you're saying
their name is a proper noun as a people
when you're saying you're basically like
saying like the Hill People when you say
like the Ukraine you know what I mean
like oh the the people in the outskirts
so it's not a national identity so they
were like and this is that's what I was
told all right this is a good one we got
OMG puppy says Canadian journalist last
night was interviewing an azov guy in
Kiev he dropped the n-word at one point
and they freaked out afraid for their
live stream as they should be that's
hate speech it's worth getting a hold of
that video so who who was a Canadian
journalist I saw I saw somebody and I'll
you know Green assault but I saw
somebody saying because I look for it
and I couldn't find it but somebody was
even saying that as of you could find
like on eBay and Amazon like as of
shirts and stuff I saw somebody I don't
think I still realize it's a Neo-Nazi I
saw the Tweet but then I went and
checked it and I couldn't find it myself
how many people you think understand
it's a Neo-Nazi group I think a lot of
people do know but but it but I think
it's important to say that they're it's
like uh Lauren said there's components
of it that are Nazis is it more is it
more correct to say that that way like
some people have super chatted saying
sang the as of Battalion is a Nazi Guru
is missing the Nuance of components of
the as of Battalion are Nazis well
there's there's many battalions as well
right
and so and there's there's one overall
you know oligarchy who's funded them and
funded a lot of politicians in Ukraine
uh as well as media outlets and that's
really been bankrolling a lot of this
stuff so yeah I mean again you know to
say Russia is controlled by the
oligarchs it is and then Putin on top of
that but Ukraine has just as many
oligarchs as Russia does uh you know
proportionately Justin Wooten says are
you suggesting anchor kittens is the
funniest thing I've ever heard let Pozo
roll the hundred-sided die all right all
right let's do it let's do it here we go
rolling it up you want to try to do this
on camera it's going to roll very far
though it's like a ball yeah
well there it goes that's a big deal Ian
rolling rolling
Lydia keep him honest keep him honest oh
it's turning around turning oh it's
coming back to me whoa oh boy that was a
powerful role that was a Michael over
40. he rolled a 44. 44. we have a 22 a
54. so 44 in China that would be is
because if the word four is associated
with death so that's double death oh
does that mean life but in clue I could
get to like literally the the library
from the ballroom with a 45
sorry you get to go back right out of
the gate
so double death yeah
love before very stable number that's
why they make tables with four legs hey
Connect Four
Anthony Austin says Tim civil defense
should be reactivated and bunkers built
for the public you know when you walk
around New York you see a lot of those
signs fallout shelter
I wonder if like I don't know anybody
who has any idea how to use those or
what you do in the event of an actual
nuke right it's like it's like I was
saying before we've forgotten sort of
all the rules all the you know the
where's the manual for Cold War can we
can somebody dust it off and can we go
back to read that there's like a wives
tale that we had a secret sealed off
swimming pool underground bomb shelter
at our high school no one ever found I
yeah did you guys have one too actually
so when I in my grade school outside
Philadelphia we actually had we had a
straight up bunker I remember going into
it I remember it having like the
radiation logo on it it had the door I
remember in I remember doing at least
one desk drill and I remember even then
thinking like I don't know how this
stops a missile but okay you know I
guess the idea is if it hits the school
it stops the rubble or if the windows
get blown out you don't take it in the
face right right so you know shrapnel
but then in the 80s if you were which I
am if the propaganda in the 80s that
this was all Reagan's fault he was going
to do this all the little kids please
Ronald Reagan stop us stop the war let's
read some more we got GBP says World
economic Forum wants us on crypto look
up the world economic Forum strategic
intelligence web with blockchain linked
to every aspect of life I've been saying
this my friends let me tell you a story
back in I think it was 2016 or 17. uh I
went to Davos because I have friends who
were working in crypto and the world
economic form at the time they have
peripheral events outside so in Davos
the city they have the world economic
Forum which is highly secure then they
have the entire city it's like South by
Southwest basically like the entire city
goes convention mode crypto was was it
oh wow everyone was talking about it I
actually had a conversation with the
granddaughter of a world leader about
Bitcoin
yeah I ended up leaving early because I
was like this is insane there's a
blizzard they call it the Internet of
Things it was like there was like a
blizzard it was like five feet of snow
it's crazy we were gonna go snowboarding
but there's like Avalanche risk it was
so it was so it's so amazing up there
though when you drive in and like you
can see like the mountains and
everything it's crazy dude I'm concerned
with mind control like they are already
doing it with the media obviously you
can see people getting mind controlled
but like real like when they start
tapping in and changing brain waves and
stuff maybe there already are but I
don't think so I haven't seen evidence
all right Bobcat says Tim forget your
Hollywood image of nuclear war it would
look more like the slow escalation of
the game Twilight to 2000 ask Jack even
I used to play that game 2000 it was
like a World War III uh dungeon dragons
game but it was we had tanks and Humvees
and stuff it was really cool your guys
stats and weapons the problem we've had
with playing dungeon dragons here or
whatever we tried to do with it is that
everyone's too roguish
you know you've gotta learn how to have
fun and just chill with it but it would
be fun to do yeah you got to learn how
to lose to enjoy losing and make a funny
funny show out of it well it's not
really about winning it's about creating
a show for dungeon master I suppose like
all the players too because it's more
about just like putting on a show than
about winning a game there's no real
Victory Condition it's about having fun
but I would love to film some kind of uh
if we took all the politics today into
Twilight 2000 or a game like that and
then played out a scenario and like yeah
I like aberrant we should check out if
we replace mutants in your superpowers
well we should we should do uh 2024 2024
election DND oh my gosh can we yes like
rather than a a dungeon it's like the
the Hall of Congress and you have to go
from room to room and I can be Nancy
Pelosi and these are my these are my
powers and you roll the dice and there's
a quorum vote and you all have to oh my
gosh I would play that game in a
heartbeat but it would be funny to be
like 2024 Donald Trump is getting
elected because they did this like uh uh
like John podesta and a bunch of
Democrats did a war game they basically
played what is essentially d d about the
2020 election and then apparently like
Donna Brazil and John podesta were like
we secede from the union or like trying
to get California to secede or something
yep what a crazy crazy thing man this
isn't one of those Time magazine
articles wasn't it yeah uh no no this
was a Boston Globe but everyone everyone
basically picked it up I think Atlanta
yeah all right let's see uh nematon says
Jack can you speak to uh speak some to
your understanding of China's 100 Year
plans and how this may play into their
current geopolitical position few people
get to develop much longer strategic
plans and are ridiculously patient
well look I mean I you know I think this
has been said before but in a nutshell
so the founding of the CCP was in 19 or
not the founding with the founding of
the PRC was in uh 1949 so the 100 year
plan will come to culmination in 2049
that is a key year for them because that
is their Centenary of taking over all or
they're sending Centennial of taking
over all of China with the exception of
course of Taiwan and so the idea is they
want to be in the position where the
United States was at that point they
want to be the global hegemon and if
they can have Russia in their back
pocket if they can have Putin this
belligerent uh Thug mafioso you know
Russian mafia type who's willing to keep
you know keep Europe at Bay then they
will do so and of course what China will
do here it's very simple by the way
they'll come to Europe and they'll say
look we can keep Putin in check you just
need to make an economic deal with us
you need to give us the most favorite
status with the EU we have to work
together and then we'll talk to Putin
we'll bring him down we'll keep you guys
safe but as long as you go through US
everything's going to be okay it's your
basic it's your basic Mafia protection
racket that's going on right now and
unfortunately it's the people of Ukraine
who are the ones who have to suffer all
right we got this from Eric
vasilyev vasilyev Russian guy here
living in Maryland getting my bags ready
for these camps you're talking about if
it doesn't work out there can I come
stay with you guys
um rest assured Russian Americans if you
are but a humble American or green card
holder or just someone who is uninvolved
but you are Russian we will absolutely
hide you beneath the floorboards yes
they can come and knock and and we'll
just be like I don't know you're talking
to anybody here you ain't done nothing
wrong bro
that's right maybe that's why you're
getting slotted maybe that maybe this is
preemptive swatting we already have
Russians every time they come in they
just they don't want to be there
we've heard you have Russians
just cats cats officer they're just cats
no no no it's like I confess it's true
and they open it up and there's cats
everywhere and the cops are alike
you think they're gonna change the name
of Russian dressing to like Freedom
dressing like what they do with french
fries Freedom fries
Russian dressing
oh man
all right
Tanner Larson says great show guys Dan
what do you think about hydrogen as an
alternative way of storing energy I'm
currently working on a project regarding
water electrolysis and I'm curious if
you have input
um I I I'm not an expert on hydrogen uh
the only thing I would say is this we've
been talking about hydrogen as this
amazing energy source for 60 years if it
was as good as we were hoping it would
it would have come to fruition by now I
am a firm believer that the free market
cannot keep good things off the market
did you study Stanley Maguire's water
car I did not no apparently prediction
just came true from earlier before the
show even ended I'm so sorry we'll talk
later
kinzinger just called for enough
kinsinger just said this proves we need
to have a no-fly zone
they watch this show I don't know if
they were watching when we were doing
the uh I'm telling you guys but they
followed our advice on the camera
positions have you bought your beans yet
because you don't want to be fighting
over the last can of beans with Agnes no
no no it's good it's good I'll share the
beans get ready to split your food in
half and share with your neighbor and
they get ready to split it half over and
over and over just like Jesus did to
feed all those people well he multiplied
it like cutting it in half multiplied
I'm a literologist also uh but that's
not what literally it's like Lindsey
Graham has just Lindsey Graham has just
called for President Putin's
assassination I I just saw that and I'm
trying to I'm trying to pull up a
sources no it's his own Twitter is that
a Hague
his own Twitter account is there a
Brutus in Russia is there a more
successful colonel stauffenberg in the
Russian military the only way this ends
is for someone in Russia to take this
guy out you would be doing your country
in the world a great service okay
Lindsey Graham's out of control he's
drunk and he needs to be removed from
Power you know if they're they're uh
leader gets assassinated the Russian
people will certainly stop supporting
the war effort I can't imagine that
nobody worse than Putin would ever come
up yeah
this is a statement that will be a
chapter in history books when a U.S
senator called for the assassination of
the president of a warring Nation
call that moment I wonder what Russian
TV is going to do with this yeah wow I
wonder what they're going to do I
remember when we uh got rid of trump
because we didn't like Mean Tweets yep
Lindsey Graham should resign over this
stuff that's awful no I just tweeted
that that's you need to resign he needs
to resign here we have it right here is
there a Brutus in Russia which is
obviously uh uh some some Brutus is the
guy that killed Caesar stabbed him in
the back yeah one of the guys one of the
guys yeah is there a more successful
colonel stauffenberg in the Russian
military the only way is for somebody to
take this guy out what these people are
psychotic man
want war that's insane that's just
absolutely Insanity to tweet that it's
like that's that's it's beyond
escalation it's it's hardly
irresponsible it's very well said thank
you I was looking for good words thank
you thank you he needs to resign because
this is dangerously close to um informal
War declaration I don't know what
whatever Russia's polar bureau if a
similar person had called for the
assassination of Joe Biden Lindsey
Graham himself would be talking about
how that is that an act of War I do not
like this guy no I can't Lindsey Graham
is trash he needs to be primaried he
needs to re this this is like bro quit
now
I can't believe this man the people of
South Carolina you all need to start
calling him and telling him to retire to
resign retire he just what an unhinged
thing to say in general I'm trying to
figure out if it's a war crime is it a
war crime to call for an assassination
do the to I mean our assassin's war
crimes Twitter's terms of service allow
this like we're not at war with us I
actually don't know how Twitter's terms
of service can allow this yeah remember
Trump was bad you would be doing your
country and the world a great service
how is this violence it's beyond him
saying that's crazy like threatening
Putin's life so Trump has been him
praising the action as honorable and a
service
crazy man plus he's keep in mind this is
a US government official an extremely
powerful U.S government official who's
about to become part of the majority of
the U.S Senate coming you know coming up
in September or November I thought
you're going to say who's about retired
I think they do yeah I'm on the fence I
think that well it's it's clearly a jump
ball I know we talk about it's sad to
see good Congress people go if they have
term limits but this is complete
ludicrous soap beyond the pill be on the
pill this is like this guy this guy is
just out of his effing mind
I mean it's so stupid too like even if
it would be a good strategy to have him
assassinated is it's such a stupid thing
to say the reason assassinations are
never good strategy yeah in general is
because you don't know what's exactly
look what happened when Brutus
assassinated and the rest of senators
asked Angela seizure you've got Caesar
Augustus and he turned the Republic into
a full-on Empire and the triumvirate had
them all killed I want to give a shout
out to uh no I I agree I mean my point
is like read the rest of the stories
the way I guess my point is like it's
it's an insane thing to even propose but
then the way of just like saying it on
Twitter and that's how he's gonna make
that thought known to the world
a Super Chat who said Lindsey Graham
calling for Putin assassination wild
times he he posted that
um before we we got the source we picked
it up but uh no free speech super chat
if he's in Congress and they're debating
this and he brings it up free speech
it's on the table maybe not ethical but
it's on the table you don't tweet it out
dude you have that literally a weapon
you gotta use it like a weapon by the
way now you're gonna have
Russians responding now yes he has
completely undermined the U.S Vladimir
Putin can now come out and say people of
Russia American politicians are trying
to get me killed we these people will
not negotiate with us they have shut
down our infrastructure they are
attacking us they're waging cyber war
against us our only op your only option
is me it's it's what Jack was saying
Lindsey Graham is a [ __ ] even if it
wasn't a horrible strategy to
assassinate him and even if it wasn't a
horrible idea to propose that strategy
over Twitter he is not the person who's
in a position to do something
senator from South Carolina
Super Chat Patrick Helton says Lindsey
Graham is Right Lindsey Graham may be
technically right I just said it on Fox
too he said it on Fox he's on Fox
Lindsey Graham is right if you want
nuclear Annihilation Lindsey Graham is
right if you want war to reach every
every inch of this globe Lindsey Graham
is not correct in how you end war and
conflict he's talking about how do you
how do you stop Vladimir Putin as an
individual because if something like
this happened especially now that he's
called for it they're gonna they would
what respond with the war declaration
against us if if somebody took a move to
kill and it was because of Lindsey
Graham you get some crazy Communists
take control and by the way that that
the Kremlin is more than just one person
there's an entire infrastructure inside
that building there's an establishment
there's there's neocons right the same
way that we have neocons that are
surrounding Vladimir Putin and you can
say well okay Putin pick them because
they're loyal to him okay great now what
do you think the Putin loyalists would
do if someone assassinated Putin and
then you could say that because Lindsey
Graham just said it publicly on Fox and
publicly on Twitter that it was a
us-backed plot what what do you think
the Putin loyalists would respond in
that scenario just just they'd probably
start planning a hundred years of war
with the United States cannot think
Beyond first order effects this is the
same problem that you see on the left
and the retinue Liberals new
conservatives they cannot think Beyond
first order effects yep that's right
it's really what it comes down to it's
like most people I don't know how many
times I can say it's stupid and
dangerous like and still be effective
and it makes and as Tim was just saying
it makes Putin now it gives them the
opportunity to go on the camera tomorrow
and say the United States government is
calling for my assassination and not
only have they punished usually now they
are calling to kill me and all I am
trying to do is fight for Russia so you
he's going to Let's specify this so now
you've been Graham doing this and not
the American government yeah you've
given Putin another weapon now he's
gonna say a country that invaded another
country Iraq and then later came out and
said it was an intelligence error and
destroyed a country
has the nerve to lecture us because
we're defending our borders
as they they attempt regime change and
now because of Russia's willingness to
defend itself they have called for my
death that's what he's going to say who
by the way you know Lindsey Graham was a
huge supporter of euromaidon he went
over there with John McCain uh with
Victoria Newell and with so many of
these people very early on in 2013 2014
he's with portoshenko
um he's he's been tied into this
directly so that's at the same token I
guarantee you Russian TV is going to be
playing that clip of Lindsey Graham and
then showing the pictures of Lindsey
Graham being with the Ukrainian military
and this is going to be a massive
propaganda coup for Putin
after tonight man I really do think we
are heading towards uh a very serious
escalation with with the the kinzinger
with Lindsey Graham yeah but they're
both morons it doesn't it doesn't matter
that the establishment has chosen its
narrative and they're going to just
steamroll through and you're going to
get sick of fans and lunatics who are
going to be like we have to we must do
it same as it always happens the
anti-war anti-war voices I mean Lee Camp
is a strong anti-war voice so of course
well and the question becomes then do
people like Lindsey Graham know what
they're doing do they know exactly what
they're doing I don't think they care
all right let's do this we're going to
go to the member we're gonna record the
the member segment and go in more detail
on a lot of what's going on we have a
couple stories we're going to cover so
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and uh you can go to timcast.com become
a member while that member segment up
around 11 or so PM you can follow the
show at timcastirl you can follow me at
timcast basically everywhere you want to
shout anything out Jack yeah follow us
human events Daily Apple podcast Spotify
wherever you get your podcast of course
because there is so much unrest going on
in the world today but you do not need
to experience unrest you can experience
the best rest of your night the best
sleep of your whole the best language
with mypillow.com
beautiful that was very nice Dale Turner
down turning part of the Future Part of
the future.com on social media and
Bristol Farm Virginia at Instagram Farm
Virginia take a break from all of this
war talk and look at two men raising
sheep puppies it's a lovely sheep farm
in Virginia Bristol Farm Virginia on
Instagram will follow us we like people
my name is Seamus goglin see my work at
Freedom Tunes we just released a cartoon
making fun of Joe Biden's state of the
union today I think you guys are really
going to enjoy it we're going to be
releasing one next week on the military
and it's wonderful uh diversity
requirements and so I think you guys
will like that too if you want to go
over there and subscribe Freedom Tunes
thank you very much and it's been great
to to chat with everyone yeah I have
about 80 million things to say but I'll
just say this I love you I love you no I
love you I love you bye everyone bye
it's been an insane night thank you all
for tuning in it's gonna be a really
great post show I'm sure as well so if
you're not already a member at
timcast.com go join us there you can
find me on Twitter and minds.com at Sour
Patch Lids we will see you all at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out we'll
check you out in the member segment bye
guys